[Musique]
Marc Tati, bonsoir.
Bonsoir cher Sky et bonsoir à toutes et
à tous. Ravi de vous retrouver hein
depuis ça fait un an et demi je crois
qu'on s'est vu et
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
interdite qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bah voilà,
je suis toujours Marc Toit l'économiste.
Donc alors faut que je raconte un petit
peu ma vie, je me rappelle plus. Oui, on
peut on peut voilà moi je viens de citer
HLM d'Orly, je dis toujours à ch parce
que c'est quand on voit un enfin un
économiste en absent que c'est un
banquier et cetera, non parce que j'ai
une cravate. J'ai des cité chl d'Orly
donc j'ai commencé bas puis j'ai réussi
à m'en sortir. J'ai commencé ma carrière
comme prof à la fac puis après j'ai j'ai
cris les studes économiques à la banque
populaire et après qui est devenu une
anexiste banque populaire. En bref et
après en 2007, j'ai quitté cette banque
et puis j'ai créé mon cabinet donc qui
s'appelle la CDFI qui veut dire aux
commandes de l'économie et de la
finance. Et voilà puis je suis toujours
là donc j'essaie simplement de
démocratiser l'économie et donc j'ai
maintenant ma chaîne effectivement
YouTube donc Marc Pot TV et qui a bien
boosté grâce à notre dernière entrevue
d'ailleurs et je pense que là ça va
encore j'espère bientôt atteindre les
500000 abonnés. Là, on est à quasiment
250000. Donc c'est bien, ça veut dire
que l'économie intéresse. Voilà, ça qui
et on le voit aujourd'hu en parler bien
sûr hein autour de monsieur de la dette
publique et de monsieur Bairou. Euh donc
c'est vrai que c'est important de parler
d'économie et les Français on peut plus
les avoir parce qu'en gros c'est moi je
pense que c'est assez malsin parce que
les les politiques, les économistes
également ont alimenté ce manque de
culture économique en disant bah comme
ça on fera ce qu'on veut. Je me souviens
il y a il y a très longtemps au début de
Marcère, peut-être en 2000, ça devait
être euh et quand je je commençais
justement à essayer de démocratiser
l'économie à l'époque, j'étais le chef
économiste de la Banque Populaire et un
des économistes, on va pas le nommer
parce que par charité, on va dire, qui
est toujours là maintenant il est quand
même assez âgé et il m'avait dit euh euh
il m'avait dit "Marc, tu sais, il y a un
problème avec toi, on te comprend trop
quand tu parles, tu comprends ? Donc tu
tu as pas tu comprends ? Nous, on doit
mettre une distance avec les gens, avec
les gens, nous sommes des experts et
cetera." Je regardé, je dis "Mais
écoute, excuse-moi mais tu as rien
compris." Tu vois, c'est exactement
l'inverse qu'il faut faire. Et donc
c'est ça qui est dramatique et je le
revois de temps en temps, je vois
certains, ils me regardent, tu sais, ils
ont toujours un petit peu peut-être pas
cette haine mais un petit peu de
jalousie quoi. Tu pourquoi on y a pas
pensé ? Pourquoi on l'a pas fait ? Et je
pense que c'est ça qui est très
important aujourd'hui. Il faut arrêter.
Quand on voit les politiques sont
complètement déconnectés de la réalité.
Quand tu vois que monsieur Baou, il dit
"Si va mal en France, c'est à cause des
Français. C'est eux qui ont fait monter
la dette publique." Enfin, c'est quand
même assez incroyable de dire une telle
inepsie. C'est les dirigeants français,
hein, on va en parler. Moi, j'ai souvent
justement limité pour arrêter
d'augmenter cette dette. Euh je me
souviens en 2000 2021 à peu près, donc
c'était après le Covid, enfin c'est on
était encore là, mais on comprenait que
c'était pas la fin du monde parce que
c'est vrai qu'au début de de ce Covid,
en 2020, Bruno Lemer, nous avait réunui
quelques économistes et puis bien sur
les haut fonctionnaires en disant voilà
ça y est, on va tout fermer, on va on va
fermer la France. Moi je dis attendez,
je comprends pas, ben faut peut-être pas
enfermer tout le monde, peut-être les
personnes à risquent. Ah non non, on n'
pas de masque, c'est très dangereux, il
va avoir des centaines de milliers de
morts, enfin des des scénarios
catastrophes. Mais attendez, mais qui va
financer ? Bah fameuse phrase de Macron.
L'État payera évidemment et la Banque
centrale européenne financera derrière.
Et donc euh voilà, c'est ce qu'on a
fait. OK. Bon, quand on a compris que
c'était pas la fin du monde, moi j'ai
dit tout simplement une une autre
réunion à Ber en 2021 en disant donc
non, il faut peut-être arrêter
d'augmenter la dette publique. Et là,
tous les économistes qui étaient
présents, les les haut fonctionnaires de
Ber me sautent dessus, enfin pas
physiquement bien sûr, mais par les
paroles me dire non mais pas du tout, la
dette publique, on s'en fiche
complètement, on va la faire rouler, de
toute façon, ça ne coûte rien, c'est
financé par la banque centrale
européenne, par la planche à les taux
d'intérêts n'augmenteront jamais. Moi,
je croyais dans un cauchemar, tu vois.
C'est dire, il me sort une connerie
pareil. Excuse-moi l'expression, je dis
ben non, mais pas du tout. Regardez,
l'inflation est déjà en train
d'augmenter. L'inflation, elle a
augmenté. C'est pas avec la guerre en
Ukraine. Évidemment, ça a mis de l'huile
sur le feu, mais elle a déjà augmenté en
2021 parce que justement, on avait créé
trop de monnaie, si tu veux, c'est la
règle de base de l'économie. Si tu crées
trop de monnaie par rapport à la réalité
économique, ben l'inflation flambe et ça
c'est ce qui s'est produit. Et donc, on
avait un manque de discernement
incroyable. Ça c'est pas les Français
qui l'ont fait, c'est effectivement les
dirigeants français. Et encore une fois
quand on voit les chiffres parce que moi
j'aime bien donner des chiffres parce
que les chiffres ne ment jamais tu vois
ce que je vais sur ma chaîne YouTube
c'est qu'effectivement je montre les
choses parce que parler c'est facile
montrer effectivement avec des sources
hein comme tu le fais régulièrement
d'ailleurs mais ça c'est c'est
déterminant et donc quand tu vois les
chiffres simples hein de depuis la fin
2019 à aujourd'hui la dette publique a
augmenté de quasiment 1000 milliards
d'euros alors que sur la même période le
PIB français ça veut dire la richesse
qu'on crée en France augmenté de
l'inflation a augmenté de 550 milliards
d'euros 1000 milliards 550 il manque 450
milliards d'euros qui ont disparu.
C'estàd qu'ils ont ils ont été utilisé à
mauvaise essence. Ça a été gaspillé tout
simplement pour tu te rends compte ce
qu'on fait avec 450 milliards d'euros.
Donc c'est ça qui n'est pas acceptable.
Ça c'est pas les Français, c'est aussi
aux dirigeants de faire le travail.
Quand tu vois par exle c'est c'est ces
économistes, il y en a encore
aujourd'hui qui disent la même chose
hein ou des hommes politiques qui disent
la dette publique ne nous coûte rien. Ça
c'est un scandale et honé quand tu vois
que chaque année la charge d'intérêt de
la dette cette année par exemple coûter
70 milliards d'euros et bientôt 100
milliards d'euros sur une année. J'ai
regardé les simulations de Bercy de 2015
à 2030 donc en 15 ans. Au total la
charge d'intérêt de la dette tiens-toi
bien c'est 1000 milliards d'euros. Tu te
rends compte 1000 milliards d'euros
juste pour les intérêts de la dette. Je
dis vraiment à ceux qui nous écoutent,
c'est complètement fou. 1000 milliards
d'euros jeté par les fenêtres. Donc je
dis à ceux qui nous écoutent et aux
autres, comment peut-on dire que la
dette publique ne nous coûte rien ?
Iacceptable.
Est-ce que je peux amender un peu ?
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. On est là pour
ça.
Les intérêts de la dette française par
jour nous coûtent deux fois plus que
notre consommation réelle en
hydrocarbure.
Ah ben voilà, tu tu as tout dit.
Mais si tu veux, le gros problème qu'on
a, c'est que on est dans le déni de
réalité permanent. Tu vois aujourd'hui,
encore une fois, bon monsieur Bou, bon,
il est plus là pour très longtemps, mais
enfin en tant que premier ministre, il
nous dit oui, c'est à cause des
Français. Moi, j'aurais j'aurais quand
même aimé qu'il nous disent "Attendez
les gars, ben désolé, on a fait des
bêtises parce qu'il a quand même,
n'oublions pas, il a contribué à cette
flambée de la dette publique. Tout le
monde a contribué bien entendu, mais
c'est vrai que depuis quelques années,
ça a beaucoup plus augmenté." Il a rien
dit, il a laissé faire, il est même il
était même patron du commissaire
commissariat au plan. Tu te souviens ?
Mais monsieur Macron l'avait mis
justement pour lui donner un petit
strapontin. Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Quatre rapports payé je sais pas
combien. Bon, faut être sérieux, tu
comprends ? Il
pas bénévole quand il était là-bas.
Oui, mais il y a il y a quand même il y
a des frais de fonctionnement. C'est ça
le problème. C'est que quand tu vois par
exle dit tu as 5 5700 élus en France,
ils sont pas tous payés mais tu as des
frais de fonctionnement autour. C'est ça
qui coûte cher et justement. C'est là où
j'en arrive parce qu'on dit souvent en
France où ce qui coûte cher c'est les
dépenses sociales dans les dépenses
publiques. C'est vrai. Dépenses sociales
c'est à peu près 42 % des dépenses
publiques au total.
C'est les retraites, les soins, c'est
quoi ?
Alors voilà, c'est c'est tout. C'est
effectivement ce qu'on appelle les
prestations sociales. Après, je
reviendrai sur les retraites parce que
là aussi c'est très important mais donc
ça augmenté effectivement de l'ordre de
12 % depuis 2021. Par contre, qu'est-ce
qui a le plus augmenté dans la dépense
publique depuis 2021 ? Et ça évidemment
les gens français ne le savent pas.
Alors moi je le dis sur ma chaîne
YouTube, je le dis ici mais beaucoup ne
veulent pas le voir. C'est-à-dire que et
ça c'est pas c'est pas mes chiffres pas
moi qui l'invente. Ce sont les chiffres
de l'INC. Ce qui a le plus augmenté ce
sont les dépenses de fonctionnement.
22 % d'augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement. Ça veut dire quasiment
100 milliards d'euros. En
combien de temps ?
Depuis 2021, tu vois, jusqu'à 1er
trimestre 2025 parce qu'on a pas encore
les chiffres de de la fin d'année, tu
vois. Donc c'est quoi ? C'est c'est
inadmissible. Tu vois ? Donc c'est quoi
les dépenses de fonctionnement ? Ben
c'est les salaires, c'est les frais
diverses des variés, c'est justement le
fonctionnement euh des des des agences
de de la puissance publique au sens
large. Et c'est ça qui colle pas, c'est
que effectivement si tu augmentes tes
dépenses euh pour les les infirmiers,
pour les services justement qui soignent
les gens ou pour les profs et cetera,
mais non, c'est c'est les dépenses de
fonctionnement qui gravitent autour, qui
augmentent le plus, tu vois. Et c'est ça
qui est très dangereux. Et donc je
termine sur ça, quand tu vois
aujourd'hui euh parce qu'on me dit mais
comment vous allez faire pour réduire
les dépenses ? Alors moi je dis toujours
moi j'ai j'ai ce que j'appelle une
thérapie de choc bienveillante. Ça veut
dire tu vois il faut euh là aujourd'hui
ce que ce qu'a proposé Baou c'était
voilà c'était euh du paracétamol quoi.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? C'est bon
sauf que tuas un un malade très
gravement malade en l'occurrence la
France tu lui dis bon on donner un peu
un peu de paracétamol et puis ça ira
mieux. Ben non ça suffit pas. Il faut
une thérapie de choc mais bienveillante.
Tu as mal tu as mal au ventre pète un
coup.
Ouais voilà. Ouais, c'est ça ce que je
propose mais là c'est beaucoup plus
grave malheureusement. Donc c'est ça qui
est grave, c'est que tu as donc cette
thérapie de choc entre guillemets. Il il
y a deux grandes mesures si tu veux.
D'abord il faut restaurer la confiance.
Moi ce qui ce qui m'est frais pour tout
te dire c'est l'état de défiance des
Français déjà dans leurs dirigeants et
dans l'avenir. Comme tu le sais, je fais
beaucoup de conférences en province et
et ma Paris aussi mais en province
encore plus fort justement. Et c'est
pour ça le problème du parisianisme
c'estàd les dirigeants ne se rendent pas
compte de la réalité. Moi je vois, je
suis stupéfait de voir parce que je fais
des conférences beaucoup chez des chefs
d'entreprise ou chez des personnes qui
qui ont du patrimoine et cetera. Enfin,
c'est auprès des banques notamment. Donc
je fais pas les particuliers he je l'ai
tout de suite. Mais donc ils ont une une
haine incroyable.
Tu fais pas de réunion tuperware ? Non,
je suis pas du non, pas encore. Ça
arrivera peut-être un jour mais pas
encore. Et donc ils ont une une haine
incroyable à gard de nos dirigeants. Et
ça, je pense que je sais pas s'ils en
sont conscients ou pas mais ça c'est
quand même très grave. Et encore une
fois, c'est des personnes des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont les mains dans le
cambouille. C'est des gens qui ont créé
des emplois, qui ont créé de la richesse
qui
protèg leur salari
qui protègent leur salariés, tu vois. Et
et là voilà, ils ne se sentent plus du
tout évidemment soutenus. D'ailleurs, tu
vois bien les chiffres. On a un record
historique de faillite d'entreprise en
France, chiffre de la Banque de France.
On n jamais vu ça. Et nous on te dit
"Bah non, tout va bien dans le meilleur
des mondes." Attendez, ce n'est pas
sérieux. Tu sais, j'ai sorti un t-shirt
comme tu l'as vu, ce n'est pas sérieux
parce que effectivement ça commence à ça
commence à bien faire. Donc je mets sur
ma thérapie de choc. Il faut redonner
effectivement confiance. Comment on
redonne confiance à tous les Français ?
On baisse les impôts. Les impôts sur les
entreprises et bien sûr sur les ménages.
Par exemple, la CAG. CG qui que tout le
monde paye et qui est un impôt qui à la
base écrit par Michel Rocard en 91 pour
financer
paix à son âme.
Voilà. Tout à fait. Pour financer je
dirais la la sécurité sociale à l'époque
c'était 1 %. Donc à l'époque il nous
avait dit bon voilà 1 % les gars vous
êtes prêt à accepter. Tout le monde a
dit bon d'accord 1 % sauf que maintenant
c'est combien ? C'est 9 %. Sur l'épargne
c'est 17,2 %. Donc on s'est bien fait
arnaquer. Pareil pour la CRDS qui devait
ça a été créé par Jupé hein. Donc ça
aussi c'est pour financer la SQ. Tu
vois, à chaque fois, on nous dit voilà
et donc ça devait durer euh 14 15 ans tu
vois c'était en 96. On y est encore
aujourd'hui, tu vois. Et on dit que ça
va, on aura encore pour au moins 15 ans,
tu vois. Bon, donc là, tu baisses la
CAG. Moi, j'ai fait des simulations 30
milliards d'euros comme tous les
Français payent la CAG. Parce que si tu
es salarié, tu payes la CAG. Si tu es
patron, tu payes la CAG. Si tu es
chômeur, tu payes la CAG. Si tu es
étudiant et que tu as une bourse, tu
payes la CG. Bon, tout le monde la paye.
OK. Épargnant pareil. Donc là, tout le
monde voit que on a fait un petit effort
pour donc tu resteras la confiance.
pareil sur les entreprises, tu baisses
l'impôt sur la production, l'impôt que
tu payes, même si tu as gagné 0 centimes
et ben tu dois quand même le payer. Tu
vois, c'est quand même un petit peu
dommageable. Il a quasiment plus de pays
qui ont ça sauf nous. Tu arrives à cela,
tu restes la confiance. Et
l'impôt sur les successions aussi, tu le
baisses.
Oui, encore une fois. Bon, ça c'est
voilà, c'est c'est comment dire ? C'est
un peu la partie émergée de l'berg,
c'està dire c'est c'est le bouqu
émissaire idéal, tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Ça ramène pas grand-chose
finalement quand tu vois tous les
Français fortunés, il y en a de moins en
moins hein qui habitent en France parce
qu'ils ont parti de ce moment des
milliardé de 200 ou 300 % non depuis
alors tu veux dire dans le monde tu veux
dire dans le monde en France alors le
problème c'est que c'est très compliqué
de les isoler mais moi je suis to avec
toi ça c'est un autre problème. C'estàd
qu'effectivement comme on est dans un un
univers ouvert hein le monde est ouvert.
Donc quand quelqu'un gagne de l'argent
il en gagne très vite. Enfin c'est quand
c'est une vraie success story. Tu l'as
vu avec les les gars femmes aux
États-Unis, mais tu vois également sur
le luxe en France. Là, comme tout le
monde en veut, c'est mondial parce
qu'avant tu avais un marché français, tu
un marché européen, là tu as un marché
mondial. Donc les sommes montent très
vite. Et si le le le dirigeant, c'est le
l'actionnaire principal, évidemment ça
peut aller très vite, ça peut aussi
aller très bas jamais les actions
baissent, tu vois. Donc faut être
prudent par par moi ce qui me dérange
comme tu le sais comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure moi j'ai décidé à HLM d'Orly
c'est dire je viens d'en bas à la
rigueur bon qui est des très riches tant
mieux pour eux à la rigueur il payent
déjà des impôts. Faut quand même pas
exagérer. Moi ce qui me dérange, c'est
je pense à moi, c'està dire à mes
parents, ils sont plus là
malheureusement, je pense merci. Je
pense effectivement à voilà aux
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui comme moi
j'étais quand j'étais jeune, c'està dire
dans cité HLM et donc la classe moyenne,
tu vois, inférieure et qui aujourd'hui
sont en train de tomber.
Quel âge tuas ?
J'ai 55 ans. C'était mon anniversaire là
le 30 août, il y a donc il y a quelques
jours. 50 ans tu imagines ? Et euh je
jeis comme si je pourir et
tu es papi ?
Et je suis papi, ouais, exactement.
C'est formidable. J'ai j'ai deux petits
enfants. Alors là pour tout vous dire,
bon change de sujet là mais bon ça a
changé ma vie. C'est vrai que ça a
complètement changé ma vie.
Pap gâteau hein.
Ah ouais complètement. Et les gens se
moquent de moi parce que ils me voient
comme ça, il pas possible marc qu'est-ce
qui t'arrive ? Allez-toi.
Voilà mais bon voilà je les embrasse
d'ailleurs. Voilà je crois pas qu'ils
regardent parce qu' ils sont vraiment
tout petits. Mais bon c'est pas grave je
les ense quand même. Et donc voilà on a
effectivement cette première mesure on
baisse les impôts et d'un autre côté on
baisse les dépenses publiques et là on
me dit mais vous allez baisser quoi
comme dépenses publiques ? Et c'est là
où il y a un catalogue à la prévers.
C'est ça la chance de la France. On a
tellement de dépenses publiques que
c'est facile de les baisser. Je vais te
donner un exemple simple. Aujourd'hui en
France, tu as 700 ODAC. ODAC, c'est
organisme divers d'administration
centrale. Tu en as 700. Pas faire la
liste évidemment, mais c'est énormément.
Alors, la plus connue, c'est Météo
France. Voilà, par exemple, tu vois,
qu'on pourrait privatiser aussi hein. Là
aussi, certaines pas mal de doubl
baiss quand même mais ils ont baissé
quand même leur fonctionnement météo
France. Oui oui tout mais ça coûte alors
justement c'estes 700AC au sens large ça
coûte chaque année 150 milliards d'euros
c'est pas rien. Alors je dis pas qu'il
faut tout enlever non mais c'est clair
que il faut réduire
voilà non c'est pas c'est en fait encore
une fois la dépense publique c'est
important moi j'en ai bénéficié
justement j'avais une bourse et cetera
c'est important mais il faut que ça
marche. Quand tu vois que tu as augmenté
ta dette publique de 1000 milliards et
que tu as récupéré à la fin 550
milliards de création de richesse. Tu
vois bien que ça marche pas. C'est que
c'est quoi la dépense publique ? C'est
que je mets 100 notamment sur
l'investissement, sur l'innovation, sur
la protection sociale et je vais
récupérer 150. Voilà, là tout le monde
est d'accord
comme ce qui s'est passé avec toi et ta
bourse
par exemple.
Bah ils ont mis 100 et en impôt tuas tu
as versé 250. Alors voilà, effectivement
c'est c'est aussi un bon exemple mais si
tu veux ce que je dis pas là c'est que
sur aujourd'hui cette dépense publique
tu tu as des moyens effectivement de la
réduire même dans le projet de de
finance de loi de finance de Bairou qui
aura pas lieu parce que bon évidemment
il va pas rester euh il proposait pas 40
milliards de baisse des dépenses
publiques. 44 milliards les 44 milliards
qu'on entend partout d'économieux les
dépenses publiques devaient quand même
augmenter de 30 milliards d'euros. Donc
c'était une moindre hausse. On présente
ça comme oh c'est miraculeux. Non
attendez. Et alors là, regarde ce qui se
passe depuis quelques jours. Les taux
d'intérêt sont en train de flamber. Ça
avait déjà été le cas il y a quelques
quelques mois. Donc là, on est à 3,6 %
sur taux d'intérêt à 10 ans français. Et
à 30 ans,
on est à 4,50. Tu rends compte, on a
atteint un sommet depuis juin 2009.
Tu vois sur le toit 10, c'était un
sommet depuis novembre 2011. Donc depuis
effectivement, tu vois le c'était la
crise des subprime, la crise grecque et
cetera. Et 2009, la suite de crise des
sub prime la récession. Donc, tu avais
une vraie défiance. Voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui en France. C'està dire que
les investisseurs sont très inquiets.
Moi tous les jours je prends un peu de
temps pour leur répondre justement à
certains notamment étrangers qui me
disent qu'est-ce qui se passe en France
? Et ça évidemment c'est très dangereux.
il t'appellent, ils sont inquiets, ils
veulent quand même mettre du blé en
France ou ils se disent la France
alors si tu veux le problème c'est que
il y a passé quelque chose la semaine
dernière que personne n'a vu évidemment
c'est que le Wall Street Journal que
tous les boursiers américains lisent a
sorti un article sur la France dans
lequel justement au vitriol c'està dire
il nous dit qu'effectivement ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en France ça devient
dramatique et donc il y a pas de il y a
plus d'horizon donc notamment ils disent
oui on a été déçu de Macron on croyait
qu'il allait sauver la France faire une
nouvelle politique, ça pas du tout été
le cas. Et donc là, si tu veux, c'est à
partir de là que beaucoup commencent à
s'inquiéter. N'oublie pas qu'aujourd'hui
54 % de notre dette publique est détenue
par des étrangers et à peu près 10 %
d'Américains.
C'est pas ta source de ça,
c'est la c'est la Banque de France,
c'est l'agence France Trésor. Alors
justement pour tout te dire, moi je me
bat, enfin je me bat entre guillemets
parce qu'il y a encore quelques années,
j'ai quand même 30 ans de carrière donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a quelques années
encore et bien chaque année la Banque de
France sortait une étude et elle nous
disait voilà quels sont les détenteurs
de la dette publique, les détenteurs
étrangers. Quel pays ? Voilà, les
Allemands, les Italiens, les les
Américains, les Japonais, les Chinois.
Bon, on savait sauf que bizarrement
depuis quelques années, c'est l'omerta.
On ne sait plus qui détient quoi. On
sait qu'il y a 54 %, ça c'est un chiffre
officiel qui monte d'ailleurs hein
d'année en année et surtout on est l'un
des numéros 1 du monde parce que tu vois
souvent on dit la dette américaine,
ouais. Sauf que la dette américaine, il
y a que 20 % qui est détenu par des
étrangers. Nous, c'est 54. La dette
publique italienne par exemple 25 %
détenu par des étrangers nous 54 tu
comprends donc ça veut dire qu'on est
beaucoup plus en danger. C'est s'il se
passe quelque chose de mal c'est
étranger évidemment ils vont pas arriver
et il s'est produit quelque chose juste
au lendemain de la dissolution donc il y
a il y a à peu près un peu plus d'un an
et que là aussi c'est passé presque
inaperçu. Il y a des fonds japonais qui
ont vendu pour plusieurs milliards
d'euros de dette publique française en
une journée. Donc normalement si tu veux
quand tu quand tu as une telle vente les
taux d'intérieur a dû exploser et ça a
un petit peu augmenté mais pas
tellement. Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut
dire qu'il y a eu un échange et que les
Japonais ont trouvé un acheteur qui a
acheté automatiquement ce qu'on appelle
du gré à gré. Ça veut dire voilà j'ai x
milliard de dettes publiques français,
j'en veux plus, j'y crois plus, je vous
la vends. Donc c'est pas passé par le
marché, tu vois, c'était un échange
direct. Et ça, on ne sait pas qui a
acheté. Alors, on a des doutes mais on
ne sait pas qui a acheté. Alors, c'est
important de savoir parce que
une piste ou pas ?
Oui, ça ça ça ça commencerait par un la
lettre Q. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Je sais pas si tu vois ce que c'est.
Donc voilà, mais j'ai pas la preuve.
Donc mais
parle français ou non ?
Non, on parle pas français bien sûr. Ben
non, c'est pas des français par
définition justement, tu vois. Et donc
comme par hasard après on a vu notre
président être très proche voilà de de
ce pays-là. C'est très amusant, tu vois.
Et donc voilà. Alors, c'est quand même
dangereux. Là, on joue un jeu
extrêmement extrêmement dangereux parce
que on perd notre indépendance si tu
veux. C'est
Attends, on perd notre indépendance ou
on se fait mettre en laiss ? Bah
les deux, c'est pareil. Tu veux que
c'est l'histoire de l'humanité, elle se
se renouvelle en permanence et on a
connu des phases de pays surendettés et
cetera. C'est c'est connu ça. Sauf
qu'après qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Alors
soit ils annulent leur dette évidemment
et puis ils font faillite et là
évidemment ça devient bah souvent ça se
termine en guerre et cetera donc ça
devient une catastrophe. On souvient les
empré russes, tu vois. Les empréints
russes c'est c'est un bon exemple he
parce que les assignas non ?
Oui aussi bien sûr. Les emprins russes,
c'est intéressant de voir ça parce que
moi j'aime bien l'histoire parce que le
l'économie c'est beaucoup de l'histoire
tu vois et les emprunts russes justement
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque les
français donc il demandaient donc les
dirigeants français demandaient aux
Français justement d'acheter des
emprunts russes en disant soutenir la
Russie c'est aimer la France ah c'est
formidable. et tu dis "Ouais, vous allez
avoir des rendements formidables et
tout, ça va être génial." Et ce qu'on a
découvert après, c'est que les
politiques qui disaient ça évidemment
étaient payés. Les médias qui
véhiculaient évidemment ce message était
également payé. Sauf qu'on savait très
bien que ça servait à rien. À quoi il
servait cette dette publique ? À
entretenir les dépenses de
fonctionnement du Tsar à l'époque, tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Puis de la
Russie au sens large. Après évidemment
et la révolution russe communiste. Là
évidemment Lenine a dit "Bon attendez
vos emprè russes pour nous on on
remboursera jamais." Donc évidemment le
pays s'est mis au banc finalement de de
la société mondiale et puis il a pu plus
s'endetter. Tu vois c'est ça quand tu
annules ta dette. Problème c'est que OK
mais c'est un fusil un coup. Après si tu
as plus de dette à l'ailleur pourquoi
pas mais quand tu dois encore t'endetter
plus personne va te prêter. Donc ça il
faut bien comprendre que ça marche pas,
ça fonctionne pas. Ou alors tu as la
deuxième solution, tu deviens un vasal
de tes créditeurs, de tes créanciers.
Ceux qui détiennent ta dette, bah ils te
disent bah fais c, fais ça et tu as pas
le choix. Tu te rappelles quand tu as eu
la crise grecque, ça c'est important
justement parce que
crise grec troica.
Voilà la crise grec en fait d'être
seigneor.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à la crise
grecque ? C'est pas compliqué. Les Grecs
ont dépensé ont dépensé sans compter tu
vois et
et les impôts étaient levés à la vac à
l'époque les la les recettes publiques
de l'État c'était à peu près 25 % du PIB
grec tu vois. Donc tu vois nous c'est 50
% tu vois. Bon alors il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui le niveau deement les
Grecs ont appris ils arrivent à récolter
l'impôt à peu près quasiment comme les
Français he faut pas bon mais bon
toujours que il dépensaiit il y avait
pas de recette puis on y allait on
continuait et il y a eu surtout quelque
chose d'assez incroyable moi je l'ai
vécu de l'intérieur si tu veux c'est que
en quand on a créé la zone euro en 99
la Grèce n'était pas dans la zone euro
la première zone eur
qui c'est qui a maquillé les comptes
grecs
alors voilà c'est ça qui est important
c'est queen fait donc la Grèce dit
attends c'est pas
Nous on est le le le berceau de l'Europe
et on n'est pas dans la zone euro, c'est
pas normal. Et donc les Européens disent
la Commission européenne, écoutez,
faites des efforts en réduisant votre
déficit, en réduisant votre dette et
puis vous fera rentrer dans dans la zone
euro dans quelques années. Donc les
Grecs disent "Attendez, mais il y a un
problème, on récolte pas l'impôt,
comment on va faire ?" Et c'est là où il
arrive une banque américaine qui
s'appelle Goldman Sax et qui dit "Vous
avez un problème de cash.
J'ai la solution.
Et nous, on a le cash. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire en fait ? toutes vos
recettes du loto, des ports ports avec
un TS évidemment des aéroports et
cetera. Tout ça, toute cet argent là, on
va vous va vous la donner maintenant et
en fait tous les ans vous nous
rembourserez voilà avec cet argent
pendant pendant 10 ans, tu vois. Donc
Ah bon ? GR Grèce, on a le droit de
faire ça. Ben oui, on a le droit. Même
les Français le faisaient à l'époque he
tout le monde le faisait à l'époque.
C'est en fait la titrisation, tu vois.
Donc c'est une recette future et on te
donne l'argent maintenant et derrière
évidemment la banque prend des intérêts,
c'est logique. Donc par miracle les
Grecs réussissent à baisser leur
déficit. Donc ils arrivent, ils
reviennent devant la Commission
européenne et regardez les gars de
déficit. Ah ouais vous êtes fort
franchement ça la Commission européenne
ils sont vraiment c'est c'est des cadors
parce que c'est
qui leur interlocuteur à la banque en
question ? Ah ça je peux Il paraît que
c'était Mario Dragui mais bon mais
toujours est-il que là il y a c'est
beaucoup plus gros que ça il y en avait
d'autres bien entendu mais toujours
est-il que à partir de là la Grèce entre
dans la zone euro et donc la le miracle
se produit parce que la la Grèce entre
dans la zone euro et donc à ce moment-là
ils ont fait aucun effort mais ils
payent les taux d'intérêt allemand sur
la dette publique ils sont dans la zone
euro. Donc je dis bah alors c'est génial
la zone euro. J'ai pas réduit ma dette.
Enfin, je l'ai réduit artificiellement
et maintenant je paye des intérêts
extrêmement bas, ben je continue de
dépenser. Et donc évidemment ça
continue. Après arrive la la crise de ce
prime donc là ça commence à faire peur,
tout l'intérêt commence à augmenter et
arrivent donc le le élection grec grec
et est élu le premier ministre
socialiste euh Pape André
avec ministre des finances
Varou Faquis.
Euh non, il était pas encore Non non
non, c'est c'est plus tard. C'est plus
tard. Merci. Non, c'est après. C'est
après. Et alors donc non, c'est après
ça. Et donc il arrive et moi j'avais
fait une blague à l'époque si tu veux.
J'avais dit il y a un problème avec
parce que en fait Papandrou on aurait dû
savoir qu'il allait planter la Grèce
puisque l'anagramme de Papand Andrew ça
fait n'a pas d'euros.
Oh théorique.
Ah tu vois c'était bon on s'amuse comme
on peut quand on est économiste he tu
vois. Bref, donc j'avais dit voilà
papréou il arrive, il dit "Écoutez, les
caisses ne sont pas vides donc on va
continuer d'augmenter les dépenses parce
que ce que veulent faire aujourd'hui
certains dirigeants de gauche en
France." Et donc là, les Allemands, ils
disent "Attendez les gars, oh vous allez
vous calmer là." Donc ils disent non, on
accepte pas. Enfin, ils disent n
précisément mais bon et donc ça passe,
ça commence à clasher et au début
évidemment donc la Grèce n'arrive pas à
payer les intérêts de la dette. Puis
après, évidemment, ça commence à à
déraper. l'Allemagne veut toujours pas
qu'il rembourse et là évidemment ça
explose. Et bon après je te fasse passe
les détails. Donc justement où on va
voir une situation dramatique de la
Grèce. Finalement l'Europe avec le FMI
avec la Bale européenne accepte de
refinancer la dette grecque. Mais
attention la dette grec à l'époque
c'était 350 milliards d'euros. Donc
ailleurs c'était c'était faisable. Nous
la France c'est pas pareil hein. C'est
3500 milliards. Tuis tu as un zéro en
plus. Et donc c'est 0 à 1 milliard,
il y en a. Donc tu vois le truc ? Ah oui
quand même. Heureusement je suis pas
Bruno Lemè.
Non, ça c'est gratuit.
Non, c'est méchant. C'est méchant, c'est
méchant. Mais bon, toujours est-il que
euh voilà et qu'est-ce qui a fait
qu'est-ce qui a été le déclencheur que
les Allemands et les Européens ont dit
"On va soutenir la Grèce ?" Moi ça, je
l'ai vécu de l'intérieur parce que
j'allais souvent faire des conférences
en Grèce. J'avais quelques clients des
banques grecques. Je me rappelle très
bien une conférence notamment, c'était
au début de la crise grec, tu vois. Et
euh donc il y avait je crois qu'il y
avait le ministre de de l'économie
grecque de l'époque ou enfin ou du
budget enfin quelqu'un de un officiel.
Donc moi, j'envoie mes slides, tu vois,
de ma conférence à l'avance. Donc je dis
dans mes slides que les taux d'intérêt
grec vont augmenter. Tu vois, c'était ma
prévision. Et là, il m'appelle Attendez
Marc, non, il y a un problème là. On
peut pas dire que les taux intérques
vont augmenter. Nous, on invite
justement les investisseurs pour leur
dire que ça va baisser, qu'il faut
acheter de la dette grecque. Je dis
"Attendez, mais excusez-moi, mais c'est
ma prévision, je peux faire ?" Et là,
ils me disent "Bah non, bah alors euh on
vous paye. Vous devez dire ce qu'on
veut, ce que ce qu'on veut que vous
disiez." Je dis "Non, non, ça marche pas
comme ça. Peut-être certains ça marche
comme ça, mais pas avec moi." Donc si
vous voulez, moi je viens pas, c'est pas
grave. Mais je peux pas dire un truc
auquel je crois pas. Bon, finalement,
ils ont accepté mais bon, on a pas trop
parlé de taux d'intérêt. Bon, bref, mais
voilà où on en était à l'époque. Et donc
les officiels grecs ont été voir les
Chinois.
Et oui, ils leur ont dit voilà nous on a
un problème de financement de notre
dette, venez-vous nous aider. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont répondu les Chinois ? Ils ont
dit non, nous la dette grecque ça nous
intéresse pas. Par contre, on va on va
en acheter. Nous, ce qu'on veut c'est le
port du Piré à Athènes. Effectivement,
ils ont acheté la moitié du port du
Piré. Tu vois ça c'est un grand
enseignement. C'està-dire que quand tu
es surendetté et bien tu as besoin de
cash et donc tu vas voir des créanciers
potentiels et ils te disent "Bah oui,
bien sûr prêter de l'argent."
Vou Exactement, c'est ça qui est très
dangereux. Et tu vends également un peu
ton âme, tu vends ton indépendance. Moi,
c'est ça qui me fait peur aujourd'hui
quand justement la Banque de France et
l'agence France Trésor ne veulent pas
nous dire qui sont les étrangers qui
détiennent notre dette. Ce n'est pas
normal. On est un pays transparent
normalement. On doit nous dire ça. On
nous le dit pas. Donc c'est quand même
alors on a des suppositions mais il y a
pas de preuve, tu vois. Donc c'est ça
qui aujourd'hui est extrêmement
inquiétant. Donc c'est ce qui fait que
bien entendu demain on peut être
vraiment voilà à la solde
pour la France. On va être exposé à quoi
? à vendre les bijoux de famille, à
imposer l'épargne, à prélever sur
l'épargne pour alors il y a plusieurs
étapes déjà le problème c'est que là tu
vois ce qui se passe depuis quelques
jours ton atterrêt commence à augmenter
mais pas que en France
pas que en France parce que tu as un
mouvement évidemment mondial parce que
effectivement ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis sont supérieur
tuas aussi oui parce que tu as
l'inflation qui augmente dans ces
pays-là donc ça fait craindre le pire
pour demain donc c'est quand même une
crainte mais c'est mondial c'està dire
tu te dis cette dette publique qui a
augmenté de façon plétorique partout
elle est pas très très efficace, tu
vois. Donc tu dis pourront pas
continuer. Donc c'est à ce moment-là on
dit on va moins acheter cette dette.
Donc si tu as moins d'acheteurs de ta
dette, mécaniquement le taux d'intérêt
augmente. C'est inévitable. Et c'est
pourquoi il y a une date importante pour
la France. Il y a le 8 septembre bien
sûr
et il y a
le 10 et surtout il y a le 12 notation.
Voilà parce qu'en fait si tu veux le 12
septembre il y a l'agence de notation
FIT qui a prévu donc de d'annoncer la
note de la France. sa nouvelle note,
fait une étude et elle sort donc tous
les 6 mois une nouvelle note. Ce qui est
intéressant de voir, c'est que depuis 1
an, donc il y a eu deux études de fit
sur la France et dans les deux études,
donc son communiqué de presse officiel,
d'ailleurs je l'ai présenté sur ma
chaîne YouTube, tu tu en as parlé,
qui dit tout simplement
d'ailleurs, regardez la chaîne YouTube
de Marc,
c'est une chaîne qui nous fait gagner du
temps, c'est triangulé, c'est sourcé,
c'est pédagogique et
tu as un vrai vent d'air frais et ça
fait plaisir que tu démocratises la
connaissance économique.
On se sent moins seul grâce à toi.
Désolé pour cette petite parenthèse.
Abonnez-vous aussi à notre chaîne
Financez-vous sur Tipi.
Vas-y, je te rends le crache
non mais ce que j'ai parl c'est donc euh
donc à ce moment là euh tu m'as tu m'as
les donc il y a fit roug
non pas du tout. Non non mais que je je
pas je suis pas un commercial moi. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Mais bon mais
c'est sympa quand même de lire
effectivement. Donc Fit dit dans ces
deux communiqués dit voilà notre ça
c'est énorme attention notre modèle de
notation
nous donne une dégradation de la note de
la France. de double A moins à simple A,
c'est énorme.
Donc notre dette va plus être achetée.
Voilà. Donc attends, mais elle nous dit
ça depuis un an, sauf qu'elle dit "Mais
on va quand même pas suivre notre modèle
de notation." C'est énorme. L'agence de
notation dit "On a un modèle donc qui
est hyper puissant mais on n'écoute
pas."
Attends, je peux je peux te faire une
parenthèse. Ils sont payés par qui ces
gens-là ?
Ah bah c'est ça le problème. Par ceux
qui notent. Alors soit-disant que sur
les états c'est gratuit. Voilà.
Soit-disant. Mais bon, encore une
regardé le le rapport de l'agence de
notation chinoise qui a été créée ?
Oui. Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Bah alors
eux, ils ont déjà dégradé mais enfin ils
sont pas tellement suivis par les
investisseurs. Voilà. À part les
Chinois, tu veux donc c'est tout le
problème aujourd'hui. Les Chinois, bon
on a pas le chiffre exact mais peut-être
qu'ils détiennent 5 % de notre dette
publique. Notation, elle dit les mêmes
choses que les autres ou elle est
beaucoup
Non non, elle elle a déjà dégradé, ell
ont beaucoup moins confiance. Mais bon,
mais ça aussi on se dit bon, est-ce que
c'est crédible ? Est-ce que c'est pas
est-ce qu'ils nous en veulent ou pas ?
Bref, et donc
Fitch te dit mon modèle me dit une
dégradation mais je ne le fais pas.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je fais confiance
au gouvernement français pour réduire le
déficit public. C'est énorme. C'est ce
que je veux dire. Sachant que je te
rappelle que l'année dernière la France
est l'un des rares pays de la zone euro,
dire le seul qui a augmenté son déficit
public.
Je veux dire finch ils sont sympas.
Ah bah ils sont très sympas. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? Il y a pas que
d'ailleurs mou sont très très sympas.
Vous êtes sympa les gars.
Merci beaucoup. Sauf queen encore une
fois euh on parlait tout à l'heure crise
des submes, je te rappelle que les
dettes subprime étaient notées par ces
mêmes agences. Triple A, ça veut dire la
meilleure note parce que je fais souvent
la blague parce qu' triple A, on savait
pas ce que c'était. Je crois que c'était
l'endouillette hein. D'ailleurs,
l'endouillette tu connais, c'est 5A pour
les connaisseurs. Voilà. Exactement.
Donc
j'ai l'endouillette.
Non mais bon, c'est c'est pas grave.
Mais bon, je connais je connais la
blague. Je connais la blague en tout
cas. Et donc par à partir de 3 triple A
ça veut dire sans risque. Donc tu avais
des dettes submes, des bombard à
retardement. Les agences de notation
disent non c'est sans risque y aller
c'est triple A le truc. Donc déjà on
sait très bien qu'elles sont pas
crédibles mais
big short.
Ouais bien sûr. Excellent film. Je
conseille à tout le monde bien entendu.
Tout à fait. Et d'ailleurs j'ai fait
j'ai fait une vidéo cet été justement un
peu de c une vidéo de OTT sur ma chaîne
YouTube pour expliquer les deux grandes
crises des sub prime grecque. Tu vois
c'est un peu historique ça les étudiants
pourront la regarder également. C'est
important de parce que moi encore une
fois moi je l'ai vécu de l'intérieur,
c'est-à-dire tu vois, j'ai j'ai vécu
tout ce qui s'est passé parce que
j'étais voilà, j'étais encore à la
banque à l'époque et puis après je suis
avec Global Écoutis, bref, donc des sur
les marchés c'est c'est c'était vraiment
flippant, tu vois. Tu tu et puis la
Grèce surtout, moi j'ai j'ai encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de peine pour la
Grèce parce que bon, peut-être on en
parlera tout à l'heure, mais quand la
Grèce est tombée, quand il y a eu après
la tro et cetera, le PIB grec,
imagine-toi, a chuté de 30 % hors
inflation. 30 % de baisse de ta
richesse. Ce que ça veut dire ? Donc
quand on a - 0,5, ça tout le monde est
dans la rue - 30. Et aujourd'hui encore,
on est en 2025, donc le PIB grec quand
même il est remonté. Le niveau du PIB
grec, il est encore 15 % inférieur au
niveau de 2008.
Rends-toi compte, c'est comme si toi on
disait voilà ton revenu d'aujourd'hui
celui que tu avais en 2008, ça fait mal,
tu vois. Donc c'est ce qui peut nous
arriver hein. Attention parce que c'est
pas même si effectivement on n'est pas
la Grèce mais euh parce qu'on dit oui la
France est pas la Grèce, elle lève
l'impôt et cetera. Oui mais attention
tuas un problème de consentement à
l'impôt. Si effectivement demain tuas
une fuite de capitaux sur lesation.
Donc je termine sur l'anche de notation.
Donc ça on revient au 12 septembre où
justement elle nous dit voilà on va
on ne dégrade pas parce qu'on fait
confiance au gouvernement alors que on a
un déficit public le numéro 1 de la zone
euro. Il y a pas un pays qui fait pire
que nous. On se moquait des Italiens
dernièrement. Enfin pas nous mais les
politiques françaises moqués des
italiens notamment eux ils ont réduit
par deux leurs déficit, ils ont de la
croissance tu vois et nous on continue
d'augmenter dans ce sens et pourtant pas
de dégradation. Sauf que là le 12
septembre ça sera après le 8 donc il y
aura pas de gouvernement. Il y en a il y
en aura un mais voilà on va dire par
intérim ou ou des des missionnaires.
Comment il va pouvoir dire fit ? Comment
ils vont pouvoir dire on fait confiance
au gouvernement pour réduire le déficit
parce qu'il y a pas de budget, il y a
pas de gouvernement. Donc s'ils font
leur boulot
c'est normalement ils doivent le faire.
Ce qu'ils feront j'en sais rien. Mais
Macron va nous mettre Lombard.
Non surtout pas. Non mais ça serait une
catastrophe. Catastrophe. Encore une
fois, que veulent les Français ? Ils
veulent des dirigeants qui qui soient
conscients de leur difficultés. Là,
qu'est-ce qu'on met ? On met des
politiques, on met des haut
fonctionnaires qui sont à 10 milieux de
la réalité économique.
Est-ce qu'on peut faire une expérience
de pensée toi et moi en 2 minutes
? Avec plaisir. Je voir un peu d'eau
cette
Je t'en prie. Et comme ça je vais en
profiter pour te laisser pourant ta
flotte
parce que je suis bavard comme tu le
sais.
Non, tu es pas bavard.
On se retrouve avec des haut
fonctionnaires, on se retrouve avec des
ministres, on se retrouve avec un un
président de la République
qui peut-être en fait nous accorde du
temps en masquant la réalité de la
chose. Et puis pour lui peut-être, il se
dit en fait on travaille vraiment pour
les Français parce que la situation elle
est tellement dramatique que un jour ils
se rendront compte qu'on était vraiment
on travaillait vraiment pour eux. Ça te
fait marer ?
Ah oui, tu vois tu mets là tu me fais
rire. Excuse-moi parce que
je sais que tu fais je sais très bien
que que le alors là non, il gagne du
temps pour eux, faut être honnête. Mais
non parce que on a plus le temps, on a
plus le temps. Regarde les intérêt sont
en train d'augmenter. Jusqu'où on va
augmenter cette dette publique ? Faut
arrêter de faire n'importe quoi avec. Je
te rappelle que l'argent public, il
tombe pas du ciel, c'est nos impôts.
L'argent public, c'est l'argent des
français. Quand même pas l'oublier. Donc
on est tous prêts à payer des impôts,
mais on veut savoir où ça va. On veut
savoir comment c'est utilisé, tu vois.
On veut savoir effectivement si ça a une
utilité, si ça permet de générer une
croissance forte, de faire baisser le
chômage, si c'est juste pour colmater
les brèches, pour augmenter voilà les
odaces, pour créer des comités
théodules, pour faire plaisir à tes
copains et cetera et pour te non tu
vois. Donc ça non, ça ça passe plus. Moi
encore moi ça fait 30 ans que je fais ce
métier, je les ai tous vu les
présidents, premier ministre, ministre
de l'économie, je les ai tous vu. Je
peux te couper encore un peu ? par bien
creuser dans ton cerveau.
Toi qui connais les salles de marché,
qui connais tout ce milieulà, est-ce
qu'il y en a certains qui font de la
veille sur les fondamentaux de
soutenabilité des économies
thermo-industrielles ? Les ressources,
la production d'énergie, les barrages,
l'hydroélectrique, le solaire,
l'accession aux matières premières,
l'accessibilité aux matières premières,
le prix d'uranium, le prix de de tout
ça, du charbon et ainsi de suite
complètement. Et quand tu discutes avec
eux sur avec ces spécialistes basés sur
les matières premières critiques,
Hm hm.
qu'est-ce qu'ils te disent ?
Bah de toute façon, c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui, si on continue comme
chiffre, qui pourra est peut-être le
plus important de de de la période voilà
de de contemporaine, on va dire, au
début des années 80, tu avais à l'époque
la moitié de l'humanité
qui vivait sous le seuil de pauvreté
extrême. La moitié avec moins de 1
dollar par jour, la moitié de
l'humanité. À partir de là, certains
pays notamment en Asie, notamment la
Chine et d'autres pays asiatiques sont
dit "On peut plus continuer comme ça."
Ils ont fait des erreurs maro et ça, ils
ont tuer des millions de personnes. Bon
bref et cetera.
Il faut maintenant se développer. Donc
ils ont dit on va on va jouer le jeu de
la croissance. Donc on va se développer,
on va développer les échanges, on va
exporter et cetera. On va faire cette
fameuse mondialisation, tu vois. Et ça a
fonctionné. Si bien qu'aujourd'hui où
nous parlons, quel est le nombre de
personnes pourcentage de l'humanité qui
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté extrême
qui est maintenant autour des 2 dollars
par jour ? 8,5 %. Chiffre de la Banque
mondiale. Tu vois, tu passes de 50 % de
personnes dans une pauvreté extrême à
8,5 %. C'est encore trop bien entendu.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Mais c'est
énorme. C'est c'est un progrès
humanitaire incroyable. Si tu avais pas
eu la croissance, tu aurais pas eu ça.
Donc quand tu dis aujourd'hui, on va
faire de la décroissance, ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire bah écoutez les les
pays pauvres he désolé hein vous êtes
pauvres maintenant que vous nous
rattrapez ben stop, vous pouvez plus
faire de la croissance, ils vont jamais
accepter.
Je peux te poser une colle
bien sûr.
Entre le moment où ils étaient tous à un
dollar avec plus de 50 % et maintenant
avec environ 9 %, la dette mondiale,
elle a évolué de combien ?
Ah bah elle a explosé bien entendu. Elle
a explosé. C'estàd que encore une fois à
l'époque ce qui compte dans la dette, ça
c'est très important question est très
bonne c'est que c'est pas le niveau de
dette parce que le niveau de dette ça
veut rien dire c'est le niveau de dette
par rapport à ce que tu crées comme
richesse. C'estàd que ce qu'on appelle
la soutenabilité de la dette. Si
effectivement je m'endette, on
s'endettete tous. C'est normal, c'est
humain de s'endetter dans la société
actuelle. qu'on soit chef d'entreprise,
qu'on soit ménage pour acquérir sa
résonance principale, tuas tu as pas
l'argent pour acheter ta maison ou ton
appart, hein. Donc il faut que tu
t'embêtes pour ça. Surtout quand tu tu
viens un héritier.
Voilà. Ouais. Mais si tu es pas un
héritier comme moi, effectivement voilà
euh donc ou autre, ben tu dois
t'endetter, tu vois. Mais et même pour
un état, tu dois tu dois jouer sur
l'avenir. Tu dois innover tu vois. C'est
ça la responsabilité des dirigeants. Ils
doivent innover, tu vois. Ils doivent
penser à l'avenir. Donc tu dois
t'endetter. Moi, je dis on doit
s'endetter mais à une condition. que
cette dette soit soutenable, ça veut
dire qu'elle génère suffisamment
d'activités, donc de croissance, de
revenus si tu préfères pour au moins
rembourser les intérêts de la dette.
Puis s'il reste un peu plus, tant mieux.
Comme ça, on améliore notre niveau de
vie. Voilà, c'est ça la règle. Sauf que
nous en France, ça fait combien d'années
que c'est plus le cas pour l'État
français ?
Depuis le premier choc pétrolier ?
Non, quand même pas. Parce que là
effectivement ça fait depuis proje
pétrolier, il y a plus de d'excédent
public, il y a que des déficits. Mais
depuis 2007 en France qui est déjà
énorme chaque année juste pour payer les
intérêts de la dette, tu dois encore
t'endetter. Donc ce qu'on appelle la
bulle de la dette. Donc c'est ça qui
marche plus, tu vois. Donc effectivement
le niveau de dette mondiale a explosé
bien entendu. Mais tu as eu dans le même
temps des pays qui s'en sont sortis,
c'estàdire qui ont fait de la
croissance. Le problème maintenant,
c'est que malheureusement euh les pays
riches comme on les appelait pays
développés qui eux aussi c'était euh le
par exemple le G7 puisqueil y a encore
quelques dans les dans les années 90,
c'était plus de 50 % du PIB mondial. 7
pays. Maintenant, ça y est, c'est fini.
C'est les bricks qui sont devant nous,
notamment grâce à la Chine, disons-le,
hein, et l'Inde, hein. Mais toujours
est-il que nous, on est en train de de
tomber. C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui les
pays qu'on appelle émergent, ça nous
rassure, on dit émergent en fait, ils
ont émergé depuis bien longtemps. Par
contre, nous on immerge, tu vois. C'est
ça qui marche plus. C'est qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement nous, dire les pays
développés et bien on narrive plus à à
prendre le relais, on narrive plus à
résister, à répondre à au pays
effectivement émergents.
Ça va être biblique ce qu'on va se
prendre dans la tête,
bien sûr. Et c'est historique. Biblique,
c'est peut-être beaucoup, mais au moins
historique. Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? Oui, bien entendu. Parce que le drame
c'est et surtout surtout nous les
Français parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
préparé. On narrête pas de nous dire
depuis qu'on est tout petit mais non
vous inquiétez pas tout va bien. La
dette c'est pas grave, la dépense
publique c'est pas grave. Les impôts que
vous payez c'est pas grave. Attendez.
Sauf que là on arrive à la fin du film
encore une fois. Alors des fois on me
dit ouais ça fait quand même 3 ans que
vous disez ça. Vous vous dites ça 3 ans
même un peu plus. Moi je le dis. Je
disais ça depuis 2018. J'ai annoncé
effectivement la première fois qu'on
allait effectivement s'effondrer. Bon,
sur la France, je suis un peu plus
inquiet depuis pas mal d'années pour les
dépenses publiques, mais j'ai souvent
dit par exemple en 2009 qu'on allait
redémarrer. J'étais l'un des rares à
dire qu'on allait redémarrer parce que
justement on avait fait une telle
relance à l'époque, ça allait
redémarrer. Donc quand on me dit je suis
pessimiste, non, j'ai pas toujours été
pessimiste, je suis réaliste, tu vois.
Mais c'est vrai que en 2018, je me
rappelle très bien, je vais sortir un
lentement à l'époque pour dire
attention, c'est un monde de bullle et
ça va exploser. Et ça a explosé.
rappelle-toi en 2018, tu as eu un craque
tout a craqué si tu veux et puis après
on a donc refait la planche habillé qui
était toujours active et puis tu arrivé
le corona coronavirus alors là
évidemment c'était le le la débandade si
tu permets l'expression le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte l'argent magique et c'est
là où les responsables du monde ont été
justement irresponsables, tu vois. Alors
encore plus en France parce que nous on
s'est pas arrêté. Tu vois la plupart des
pays en 2021 dit bon allez on va
peut-être s'arrêter là ça a été un peu
loin à part les Américains mais les
Américains la différence c'est que eux
ils ont beaucoup misé sur l'innovation
et l'investissement donc c'est ma règle
de tout à l'heure. Leur dette elle est
soutenable surtout les Américains, ils
ont le dollar. Ça veut dire que tant que
le dollar
l'armée surtout
l'armée ou mais surtout ils ont le
dollar quand le effectivement le dollar
c'est 50 % des transactions dans le
monde alors que le commerce américain
c'est que 11 % du commerce mondial.
C'est-à-dire que les 2/3 du commerce en
dollars ne sont pas américains. Donc tu
as une demande mondiale de dollars, tu
comprends ? Donc tant que tu as ça, ils
sont sauvés. Le jour où ils auront plus
ça et ça arrivera un jour. Un jour, il y
aura un concurrent au dollar. Je te
rappelle que d'abord les Japonais ont
voulu le faire avec le yen. Il
y a Saddam Hussein aussi qui a essayé
sur le tradon pétrole. Il y a il y a
Kaddafi qui a essayé. Br
Oui, mais ça a pas marché parce que il
faut justement pourquoi effectivement on
achète le le pétrole en dollar par
exemple pour les matières premières ?
Parce qu'il y a une liquidité du marché.
Il voulait le trader en euros hein lui.
Ouais. Mais l'euro on a essayé aussi ça
a pas marché. Donc maintenant pourquoi
ça a pas marché ? Parce que justement on
peut pas tu peux pas pour concurrencer
le dollar il faut une dollar il faut une
devise forte une devise qui inspire
confiance. Sauf que quand tu as une
devise forte c'était l'erreur qu'on a
fait en Europe. On avait un eurofort à
un époque à une époque et ça a cassé
l'activité économique. Donc si tu as une
devise trop forte, tu casses ta
croissance, tu fais monter le chômage tu
peux pas résister, tu vois. Et c'est
pourquoi les Chinois eux, ils savent
qu'ils pourront un jour concurrencer le
dollar avec le yan, mais ils sont pas
prêts aujourd'hui. Et d'ailleurs, tu
vois bien, le yan ne s'est pas tellement
apprécié face au dollars. On est autour
des
trafique un petit peu là.
Bien sûr. Bah oui, parce que tu as le
contrôle d'échange. N'oublions pas ça.
En Chine, tu as le contrôle d'échange.
Ça ça veut dire que ben tu un Chinois
peut pas vous exp enfin peut pas
exporter ses ses yan à l'étranger s'il
veut ou acheter en dollar si veux. Il
faut l'autorisation de la banque
centrale.
Un peu comme le Maroc, non ?
Un peu comme tous les pays justement. Il
y a du contrôle des chances. Je te
rappelle que nous en France et ça c'est
ça nous pas en est hein parce que
rappelle-toi en 81 après la relance de
Mitteran qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Comme les invests voulaient enfin les
Français voulaient quitter la France
parce qu'ils avaient peur qu'on qu'on
les ponctionne et cetera. Tac on a fermé
les frontières. Ça c'est un vrai danger.
Ça c'est un vrai danger. Alors c'est un
danger extrême mais il faut savoir que
ça peut arriver. C'est que
les assurances vies peuvent faire la
même chose si tu veux liquider ton
assurance vie. Ils peuvent t'empêcher de
liquider ton assurance vie ou pas ?
Non. Mais ils peuvent pas t'empêcher,
ils peuvent t'empêcher de sortir
effectivement l'argent. Tu vois, tu dis
bon ben OK, tu la laisses à la banque
mais tu la sors pas et encore moins tu
la mets encore moins à l'étranger, tu
vois. Et donc ça c'est c'est évidemment
une mesure d'urgence mais c'est tout
c'est une mesure d'urgence, c'est
patriotique.
Non, c'est pas patriotique. C'est parce
que c'est si ça si on arrive là, c'est
parce que c'est il y a le feu au lac
comme on dit. Si on en arrive là et ça
peut arriver très vite, tu vois, parce
que encore une fois, on l'a vu la
semaine dernière là, hier taux d'intérêt
comme ça de la dette publique, il passe
de 330 à 3,60 en quelques heures, ça
peut aller très très vite, tu comprends
? Parce que encore une fois, ça fait 30
ans que je vis avec les marchés que je
les connais bien. Quand tu as un
mouvement de défiance qui s'installe, tu
peux pas la tu peux pas l'arrêter. Tu
peux pas l'arrêter. Rappelle-toi
justement après la fite de L Man
Brothers les banques en elles ne
voulaient plus se prêter.
Le VIX était monté au plafond.
Exactement. C'est quoi le
c'est l'indicateur de volatilité de la
peur
de la volatilité des marchés boursiers
notamment sur standard pour 500. Donc
effectivement plus il monte ça veut dire
que plus effectivement tuas tu as une
crainte sur l'avenir et donc tu as une
volatilité qui est très forte. Donc
c'est ça qui est particulièement
inquiétant. Mais là avant le craque
boursier, il y aura d'abord un craque
obligataire. Ça veut dire sur les
obligations d'état. Je pense que ça
c'est la clé. C'est ce qui est en train
de se produire aujourd'hui au niveau
mondial.
Alors l'Angleterre et également la
France,
Japon. Le Japon bien entendu le Japon
c'est différent parce que 95 % de la
dette publique japonaise est détenue par
des Japonais. Japonais si tu pourras pas
attaquer leur dette alors faudrait que
les Japonais eux-mêmes l'attaquent tu
vois. Par contre depuis quelques mois il
y a des petits problèmes parfois les
Japonais font des ce qu'appelle des
adjudications. Ça veut dire ils y
émettent du papier sur le marché et ils
trouvent pas preneur. Même les banques
japonaises disent non ça nous intéresse
pas. Ça c'est mauvais signe tu vois.
Alors pour l'instant, on te dit oui mais
la France ça n'est jamais arrivé. Oui,
c'est vrai que ça n'est jamais arrivé.
C'estàd pourquoi ? On a ce qu'on appelle
l'agence France Trésor qui dit "Attendez
les gars, achetez notre dette, elle est
super." On a même fait des dettes
indexées sur l'inflation en disant voilà
tu es sûr de gagner. Ce qui a coûté très
cher d'ailleurs. Très très cher. C'était
pas beaucoup.
Oui, d'accord. Mais non, mais si tu
veux,
ça coûtait cher monsieur.
On a si tu veux, on a des commerciaux
dans toutes les banques françaises,
toutes les grandes banques françaises
qui disent donc à toutes leur
contrepartie mondiale acheter de la
dette publique française. Donc c'est
quand même pas mal. C'est vachement bon
d'ailleurs.
Ah mais bien sûr, ils sont excellents.
Mais c'est là que j'aurais parce qu'on a
pas fini tout à l'heure les agences de
notation. Si tu finis effectivement
par dégrader l' de la France, là on est
encore double à moins. Donc on est
effectivement toujours dans la la
catégorie supérieure.
Si on tombe à simple A là, tu vas me
dire "Bon, ça va, c'est juste A en
moins."
Non, parce que beaucoup de compagnies
d'assurance, d'investisseurs, de
banques, de fonds de pension et cetera,
de caisse de retraite, même français
hein, et bien ont l'obligation d'acheter
du triple A ou du double A. Par contre,
quand tu tombes à simple A, tu es plus
dans le cahier des charges. Ils vont
quand même acheter ta dette mais
beaucoup moins qu'avant. Et surtout que
comme tu le sais, aujourd'hui, les
Allemands vont émettre de la dette. Donc
ça veut dire que tu es un investisseur,
l'Allemagne est toujours triple A, tu as
la France,
ils ont que 60 % d'endettement si mes
souvens.
Ouais, 70 un peu monté mais ils ont de
la marche. Ils ont de la marche. Donc si
tu veux, ça c'est très intéressant parce
que également depuis 2007, tu vois que
quand tu regardes la variation entre la
dette publique et le PIB français, c'est
x 3. C'està dire entre donc la dette
augmenté trois fois plus que le PIB
français alors que en Allemagne, ça
augmenté au même niveau.
C'est qu'on s'en dette pour produire un.
Exactement.
C'est pour avoir un point de PIB,
tu tu mets trois dettes
pour
Ah ouais mon gars. Eh ouais mon gars,
c'est c'est c'est grave.
C'est grave. Excuse-moi, je t'appelle
mon gars, tu m'en veux pas.
Je fais mon candide. Je fais mon
candide.
Non, je sais, je sais. Mais tu
comprends, c'est vrai. D'ailleurs, je le
dis parce que tout le monde me dit "Al
est-ce qu'il est sympa ? Sky, il est
très sympa." Voilà, il est très très
sympa. Non, mais c'est vrai, c'est vrai,
c'est vrai. Et et surtout, il
s'intéresse à l'économie. Ça c'est
important
depuis un certain nombre de décennies.
Exactement. Donc bravo à toi. Et donc si
on passe,
c'est pour ça qu'on t'a repéré
d'ailleurs que je nous ai gagné du
temps.
C'est gentil. Et donc c'est
effectivement on tombe la simple A, tu
es un investisseur, tu as même tu as on
va dire tu as 100000 € à investir. Tu
vas dire bon j'ai que 100000 € mais je
dois acheter la dette publique. Tu vas
dire je prends du triple A ou du simple
A. Il y a pas photo. Tu comprends ? Donc
alors après ça dépend parce que le
simple A ça va
c'est mieux que le triple B. Oui, je
suis d'accord avec toi. C'est sûr.
D'accord. Il faut jamais se comparer au
dernier de la classe mais ça va
peut-être me rapporter plus.
Non parce que le problème c'est ça,
c'est que ça c'est très important parce
que voilà parce que beaucoup nous posent
la question. Je je encore une précaution
alatoire. Cette vidéo n'a en aucun cas
la prétention de vous conseiller pour
investir.
Ah oui oui bien sûr que non. Non non moi
je moi je suis juste moi si tu veux moi
d'ailleurs parce que quelqu'un me disait
dernièrement là je vais même le dire
même mon fils qui qui aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs ta chaîne il me disait pas
c'est pas normal tu tu es pas assez
riche tu gagnes pas tu as pas gagné
assez d'argent dans ta vie. sort ça. Bon
bref, c'est vrai que je suis pas très
riche et euh alors combien ? Non, je
veux pas le dire mais bon c'est mais euh
peu importe je veux dire mais moi mais
moi pour moi si tu veux c'est ça ça
c'est ma culture c'est ve dire c'est ma
culture de mon enfance l'argent c'est
pas le plus important compte c'est le
bonheur compte c'est le kiff tu as des
gens milliardaires qui sont malheureux
tu comprends et moi moi je me suis dit
moi est-ce que je lu répondu donc je te
dis ce que dis comme réponse je dis moi
je viens de citerlm donc si tu veux mon
pour moi mon espoir c'était peut-être
peut-être d'être prof de fac tu vois
pour moi c'était le top du top tu vois
donc quand j'ai réussi à à gagner j'aime
beaucoup les profs de fac ils font un
super boulot hein mais quand j'ai réussi
à gagner un peu plus. Je me suis dit
franchement ça me suffit et tu vois moi
j'aime voilà j'aime passer du bon temps,
j'aime dépenser et c'est c'est aussi mon
père qui était comme ça d'ailleurs je le
père à son âme je l'embrasse c'est
qu'effectivement lui il y avait pas de
moyen mais voilà il dépensait plus que
ce qu'il avait tu vois ce que je veux
dire donc ça m'est resté je me dis et et
c'est vrai que chez moi, bon mon père il
avait cinq sœurs, j'avais plein de
cousins et cetera et et cousines tout le
monde était tout le temps chez moi parce
que mes grands-parents habitaient chez
moi, tu vois à Orlie dans un petit un
petit cinq pièces. Bon, c'était c'était
c'était la folie. Il y avait 40
personnes où j'étais jeune et moi c'est
c'est l'image que j'ai.
et malheureusement bon j'ai pas une j'ai
qu'une sœur j'ai pas beaucoup de neveux
niè mais néanmoins tu vois je me dis
voilà j'aime avec mes amis voilà on fait
on fait des petites fêtes on fait voilà
c'est la famille quo
c'est la famille c'est c'est ça qui
compte c'est que c'est pas un problème
d'argent c'est un problème simplement de
kiff et aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'effrait
les les les gens ils savent plus kiffer
excuse-moi l'expression
et puis on reparlera un jour de de le
côté malheureux des milliardaires qui
engendre qui engendre la maladie du
pouvoir. On fera une émission là-dessus
qu'on est en train de préparer.
Moi je te dis très honnêtement, quand
j'étais notamment dans les banques dans
lesquelles j'ai travaillé, je voyais
parfois ce que j'intervenais, tu vois,
auprès de la la banque de la banque la
banque privée, tu vois, avec des grosses
fortunes. Et je te promets, je voyais
les gens, ils étaient malheureux. Je
promets dire il comment mes enfants vont
récupérer les enfants entre eux, ils se
déchirer la fortune, le machin.
Horrible. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Donc bon, c'est vrai que c'est il faut
avoir de l'argent effectivement mais
quand tu en a trop, ça sert à rien. Tu
vois ce que je dis ? Voilà, surtout si
tu sais pas profiter de la vie. Alors
c'est encore pire parce que tu as des
gens, ils sont malheureux. Bon,
reviens sur la dette, onent
sur les agences de notation.
Voilà, effectivement c'est non mais
c'est ça c'est qu'à partir du moment où
tu es tu es dégradé donc tu tu tombes
effectivement et là on nachète plus ta
dette. Et donc là c'est là où c'est la
conséquence pour les Français, c'est que
les taux d'intérêt vont augmenter. Donc
justement pour ta question parce que
j'ai beaucoup souvent cette question, on
me dit c'est quoi effectivement le quel
est le risque pour quand les taux
d'intérêt augmentent sur les obligations
d'État ? Parce qu'on me dit si le taux
d'intérêt augmente ça c'est bon parce
que ça me ça me rapporte plus. Oui sur
les nouvelles obligations. Par contre si
toi tu as acheté une obligation
aujourd'hui d'état et que demain le taux
d'intérêt a augmenté ça veut dire que
ton obligation il y a un taux d'intérêt
inférieur au nouveau taux. Donc ton
obligation elle vaut moins cher
qu'avant.
Donc tu la vends.
Voilà. Donc si tu dois garder si tu veux
garder ton obligation par exemple 5 ans
ou 10 ans jusqu'à son terme normalement
j'espère que ta française ne fera pas
faillite. Donc on te remboursera. Par
contre, si tu dois vendre ton obligation
avant, mais là tu fais une moins value
parce que ton obligation, elle vaut
moins cher quand tu l'as acheté. Donc
c'est ça le danger. Mais après, il y a
un danger plus important pour tous les
Français, même ceux qui n'ont pas
d'épargne, parce que quand les taux
d'intérêt augmente et bien ça casse
l'activité économique. Parce que quand
les taux d'intérêt de des obligations
d'état augmente, ton intérêt de tous les
crédits augmente. Ton intérêt sur
l'immobilier, sur la consommation, sur
les entreprises. Et donc quand ton
intérêt augmente, ça casse l'activité.
Ça te fait évidemment ça casse donc
l'investissement, donc l'emploi, ça fait
monter le chômage, tu vois,
et la violence.
Ben évidemment, bien entendu. Et donc à
partir de là, tu as un risque social
énorme. Donc c'est là où peut-être, tu
vois, les Français commencent à
comprendre qu'en fait la dette, c'est
pas un problème stratosphérique. Tu
vois, quand tu vois ce qui s'est passé
en Grèce ou dans d'autres pays, quand tu
vois ce qui est en train de nous arriver
aujourd'hui, ben tous les Français
malheureusement vont payer, tu vois. Et
quand monsieur Baou dit oui, il faut que
les Français serrent la ceinture. C'est
c'est un scandale. Ça fait 40 ans que
les Français se serrent la ceinture. Par
contre les la haute fonction publique,
lui il sert pas la ceinture. Quand tu
augmentes tes dépenses de fonctionnement
de 100 milliards d'euros, donc euh
depuis 2021, 22 % de hausse, je t'ai pas
serré la ceinture, tu vois. Et donc, tu
vois ça, ce discours il passe plus. Donc
c'est pour ça que tu me dis ou là voilà
baou Lombard et cetera. des gens qui ne
sont pas au fait de la réalité
économique, ils sont trop loin, ils sont
trop éloignés. Berou berou euh si j'ai
bien compris il demande un effort mais
en fait ça paye juste les intérêts de la
dette à peine mais il va demander encore
un effort l'année prochaine et puis
l'année d'après l'année d'après parce
que il a là là c'est moi je suis
c'est comme une cure d'austérité ce qui
nous demande c'est justement c'est ce
que je dis tout à l'heure c'est que
demander un effort au français non alors
bien sûr il faut optimiser la dépense
publique faut l'améliorer améliorer son
fonctionnement lutter contre voilà les
fraudes fiscales les fraudes sociales ça
aussi les fraudes fiscales c'est pas
parce que moi je vois des j'ai des
messages de chefs d'entreprise qui qui
m' Onvoie des messages, je ferme ma
boîte. Pourquoi ? J'ai eu un contrôle
Ursaf. En fait, ils avaient s trompé
dans les déclarations, rien de méchant.
Ils sont fait exploser. Donc ils
ferment.
Ils leuront pas proposé un plan
d'étalement.
Ouais. Mais même des fois, tu as des
boîtes, rends-toi conscient de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en France. Tu as des
faillites d'entreprises qui atteignent
des sommets historiques, chiffres de la
banque de France. Donc quand on dit les
entreprises gagnent de l'argent, OK sur
le cas 40, mais la grande majorité des
entreprises françaises, elles sont en
train de s'effondrer, tu comprends ? Et
donc on est en train de leur dire non
mais c'est pas grave, continuez comme
ça. Donc évidemment c'est c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que quand
les entreprises sont faillites derrière
évidemment il y a du chômage. Donc non
moi je suis pas d'accord. Il faut pas
demander aux Français, c'est pas au
français à serrer la ceinture, d'abord
commence par le commencement. Et quand
on entend justement l'économie parallèle
et cetera, fraude fiscale, donc on va
embêter le chef d'entreprise honnête qui
a lieu de faire une déclaration. Par
contre, toute l'économie de la drogue,
toute l'économie de la mafia, toute
l'économie parallèle au sens large,
alors là eux ils sont eux ils sont
tranquilles. Je j'inv j'intervenais dans
je sais pas sur quelle chaîne là parce
que j'en ai fait beaucoup dernièrement.
Justement, il je crois que c'était LCI,
il montrait euh justement reportage euh
je crois que c'est à Orange justement
effectivement euh euh les trafiquants de
drogue en fait, ils ont ouvert des une
sorte de club de vacances, tu vois, pour
tous les enfants. Donc il dit "Voilà,
venez manger, il y a le barbecue, il y a
des jeux,
ouais, on vous donne des des livres, des
cahiers et cetera."
Wouh !
Ils achètent la paix sociale.
Non, mais d'accord. Mais c'est pas eux à
faire ça. Ça veut dire quoi ? C'est
c'est ce que faisait effectivement
Pablo Escobar. Euh
euh donc quand il a acheté effectivement
tous les t tous les quartiers, quand il
est mort tout le monde a pleuré parce
que qui va nous financer ? Attends,
c'est incroyable ce ce là mais on n'est
pas en Colombie, on est quand même on
puis même les Colombiens, ils ont ils
ont fait leur adjonamento. Attendez, où
on est aujourd'hui ? Et alors moi ce qui
m'a faré dans le reportage, c'est que il
il montrait des mamans des mamans. Et
donc on a inter Vous n'avez pas peur de
votre fils qui est là-dedans qui en
profite de ça ? Ah ben non, non, c'est
bien. Non, il nous aide. Oui, mais
peut-être que après ils vont peut-être
le solliciter pour être dans le trafic
de drogue. Bon ben c'est pas grave.
Non mais c'est c'est un truc de fou
parce que moi encore une fois je dis
d'Orly, j'ai connu ça. Ça existait déjà
à mon époque connu les pitbulles.
J'ai connu tous ces trucs là. Il y avait
des cités où tu peux pas tu pouvais pas
rentrer. Il y avait il y avait des des
échanges de tir et ça mais mais tes
parents ils te protégeaient. Ils
allaient pas te dire vas-y mon fils va
aller va faire du trafic de drogue.
Attends c'est quoi cette affaire ? Mais
c'est ça qui est dramatique c'est que
aujourd'hui tu as un taux de chômage
dans les cités. HLM pour les moins de 25
ans de l'ordre de 60 %.
Donc c'est là ça qui est fou, c'est que
normalement l'État avec l'augmentation
des dépenses publiques notamment pour la
politique de la ville et cetera, ça
aurait dû marcher. On aurait dû dire
"Mais attendez, c'est on va vous aider,
on va on va réussir à à vous faire
sortir de là." Non, on les maintient. Et
donc c'est quoi leur espoir ? C'est le
trafiquant de drogue. Ça c'est c'est
horrible. Aussi révélateur d'un mal-être
de la population en général.
Non, mais surtout mais surtout faut être
honnête, c'est quoi l'espérance de vie
pour un traficant de drogue ? à part les
les parents mais sinon c'est pas c'est
pas très vieux. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Puis surtout encore une fois que
comme on dit comme on dit dans comme dit
le film que fait la police ? Dire que
la police ils en chient quand même.
Mais c'est ce que je te dis c'est ça qui
est dramatique c'est que leur caisses
toute pourrie. Tu as vu l'état du
commissariat compris ? On leur donne pas
les moyens parce qu'on laisse faire. Moi
c'est moi c'est ça contre quoi je peste
dire qu'on va embêter aujourd'hui des
gens honnêtes. Tu as pas payé ton tu as
pas payé ton ton PV ou truc comme ça. On
va on va te tomber dessus. Le chef
d'entreprise qui au lieu de faire une
déclaration URSAF on va lui tomber
dessus. Par contre trafiquant en drogue
maintenant vous comprenez ils aident
mais c'est quoi ce discours du
l'augmentation du taux de suicide chez
les forces de l'air faut leur tirer un
faut le faire un coup de chapeau
sur le sur le leur lieu de travail à
l'aide première ligne
bien sûr et puis quand tu entends
certains politiques qui disent oui la
police tue et cetera, c'est incroyable
en arrivé là ils font du ils font de la
politique politicienne pour avoir des
voies et cetera non il faut tu vois et
ça je pense que le problème on va
remonter très haut C'est évidemment le
problème de du président.
Un pays comme la France, il a besoin
d'un chef. Il a besoin d'une direction.
Un chef irréprochable, un chef qui nous
dit où on va aller. Chef qui nous
inspire confiance. Quand tu vois le
niveau de popularité, de confiance, que
ça soit monsieur Macron, monsieur Barou,
Bairou, ça fait ça fait quand même peur.
Tu as confiance en qui là sur le le
panel des politiques ?
Pour l'instant, personne. Très
honnêtement, j'ai pas trouvé. Non. Alors
alors voilà j'allais j'allais citer
quelquesuns effectivement voilà l'istard
m'a sollicité. Oui c'est vrai qu' enfin
on a discuté il est sympa tu vois ce que
je dire même Bruno Raillo également j'ai
pas mal
Oui oui oui oui Bruno Rillo j'ai pas mal
discuté également avec lui. Bon on va
voir ce qu'il va faire après pour tout
moi
peut-être pas conscient de la réalité de
la situation hein.
Si si il est conscient mais je veux dire
le
international compliqué. Bah voilà. Non
mais peu importe, il faut des personnes
de bonne volonté et surtout il faut des
personnes proches du terrain, tu
comprends ? Et malheureusement, il y a
de moins en moins. C'est ça qui
aujourd'hui fait peur, c'est qu'on a des
personnes qui sont trop éloignées. Et
président de des maires de France, non ?
Oui, tout à fait. Alors voilà, non mais
c'est pour ça. Mais après ce qu'il aura
le je sais pas aujourd'hui je Bon,
j'espère que quelqu'un va va se lever.
Est-ce que tu as étudier les les
contrebudgets des différents spectres
politiques ?
Alors, tout le monde en a pas fait.
Alors, j'ai vu parce que je suis
intervenu justement dans une émission
télément, il y avait un réponsant du PS
: C'est une catastrophe. D'ailleurs, je
lui ai dit, je dis heureusement, vous
allez pas avoir le pouvoir parce que
sinon alors là
c'est ton interprétation. Peut-être que
pour eux ça fait sens.
Non mais non mais encore une fois si tu
veux, on a eu Hollande il y a pas
longtemps puis excuse-moi euh Macron
Lombard c'est tous des mecs un peu de
gauche. Bah pour moi c'est des mecs de
gauche honnêtement ils sont un peu
socialistes, faut quand même pas
l'oublier. Donc non
ils prétendent. Non non, ils ils ont eu
leur chance mais ça marche pas ce qu'il
propose. Augmenter les impôts, ça marche
pas. Augmenter la dépense publique, ça
marche pas. Donc non, c'est c'est c'est
monde. Moi, je pense qu'aujourd'hui
pareil pour Bairou, ce qui propose c'est
des mesurettes. Moi, je pense qu'il faut
changer de paradigme. Moi je te dis une
thérapie de choc bienveillante. Faut
changer complètement et on va me dire
c'est pas possible. Regarde ce qu'on
fait les Italiens parce c'est
intéressant parce que on me dit parfois
oui, si tu augmentes, si tu baisses la
dépense publique, tu vas faire une
récession.
OK mais non mais non pas du tout ça
dépend quelle dépense que tu baisses si
tu baisses ces dépenses de
fonctionnement que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure si tu baisses le milf
administratif qui coûte quand même 10
milliards d'euros chaque année si tu
baisses des dépenses où où certains
fonctionnaires ou élus sont payés trois
fois tu vas pas changer la la phase de
l'économie française.
Il faut augmenter le salaire des profs
augmenter les infirmières augmenter les
pompiers. Moi je dis il faut réduire
justement il faut réduire les charges ce
qui fait augmenter les salaires nets.
Moi je suis pour une baisse des impôts
globales si tu veux, une baisse des
charges mais aussi des dépenses
publiques. C'est extrêmement important
tu vois. Mais là alors justement on me
dit
est-ce qu'il faut baisser les aides aux
entreprises ?
Alors attends je vais arriver juste pour
te terminer sur le cas italien parce
qu'effectivement en Italie ils ont
baissé les dépenses publiques. C'est
l'un des pays qui a le plus baissés. En
Grèce pareil. Au Portugal pareil. Et
c'est bizarre dans ces pays-là il y a
une croissance qui redémarre. même qui
est forte au Portugal ou en Grèce. Alors
ils sont
sorti un peu du marché de l'électricité
les Portugais.
C'est sûr. Non mais d'accord mais ça
aussi peut-être qu'il faudra peut-être
sortir nous aussi que
on peut pas on est un hub énergétique
pour tout.
Ouais oui oui faudrait peut-être là
aussi il faudrait peut-être raisonner et
surtout non je sais je sais faire preuve
de bon sens. Le problème ça c'est qu'on
n plus dans le bon sens mais ça c'est la
preuve. Alors je pas parler de
l'Argentine mais l'Argentine aussi ils
ont baissé les dépenses public. Tu vois,
tu te souviens avant que Miley soit élu
en Argentine, il y avait il y avait une
enfin une une tribune de 100 économistes
du monde entier dont le fameux Piquéti
en France, tu vois. Bref, des
économistes de salon, tu vois, et qui
avait écrit gratuit
ça c'est méchant. Non mais c'est pas
méchant, c'est une réalité, je suis pour
rien. Bref, donc qu'est-ce qui
en point de vue ?
Oui. Oui. D'accord. Non mais il y a rien
de mal. Mais quand tu
Il pas là pour se défendre.
Ouais. Ouais. Donc je pas non parle pas
de lui mais quand même c'estàd que parce
que c'est le nom est dans cette
chronique mais il y a pas que lui il y
en a plein d'autres qui te disent la
dette ne coûte rien. Comment tu peux
dire un truc pareil ?
Donc la tribune sur l'Argentine.
Donc tribune sur l'Arg donc il signe 100
économistes du monde entier qui disent
si Miley est élu en Argentine le pays va
s'effondrer. Il il remontera jamais la
pente. Puis c'est fort comme tu vois.
Mais mais donc disant votez pas pour lui
et c bon il a quand même malgré ça il a
quand même été élu. Et maintenant, on
voit les chiffres de l'UFMI, hein, 7 %
de croissance. L'inflation a été
réduite, l'investissement augmente de 30
% l'an dépenses des ménages 25 % l'an
des chiffres incroyables, hors inflation
hein, des chiffres incroyables. Et même,
je crois que c'est l'UNICEF qui a
félicité Miley pour dire que la pauvreté
avait baissé.
Donc,
tu sais ce qu' faisait ?
Alors, elle est toujours élevée
évidemment, mais elle a quand même
baissé. Donc c'est vrai que au départ ça
a fait mal parce qu'il a dit bon ben on
va réduire certaines dépenses et surtout
on va lutter contre la corruption. Très
important et à partir de là ben voilà ça
redémarre parce que simplement il a il
inspire confiance et je pense que ce qui
nous fait mal aujourd'hui en France
c'est qu'on a plus du tout confiance
dans des dirigeants politiques même dans
ceux qui sont dans dans l'offre
politique actuelle.
En qui peux-tu avoir confiance ? Parce
que on sait très bien que bah voilà il y
a des échéances sur la dette publique et
cetera et ce qui te propose n'est pas
très crédible. C'est pourquoi moi je dis
aujourd'hui les ce ne sont pas ceux qui
ont créé les problèmes qui vont
solutionner les problèmes.
Albert Einstein.
Exactement. Bravo. Et donc euh une autre
phase d'Albert que j'aime beaucoup,
c'est comment la la définition de la
folie. En fait, le fou, c'est celui qui
fait constamment la même chose et il
croit qu'il y aura une conséquence
différente.
Tu connais les définitions aussi de la
connerie et de l'univers.
Oui, c'est pareil. C'est c'est ça c'est
que effectivement voilà l'univers est
infini. La connerie c'est pas sûr.
Il finir est peut-être fini. Ouais. La
connerie pas sûre. Oui, évidemment.
C'est-à-dire que encore une fois, il
faut faire preuve de bon sens. Donc
qu'est-ce que tu dis aux gens qui te
disent "Voilà Marc c'est une Cassandre,
il voit tout en noir, il nous embête."
Mais mais c'est faux. De toute façon, tu
tu me connais dans dans la vraie vie
déjà, je suis pas comme ça. Puis moi, je
suis dans la vraie vie, je suis comme
que je suis aujourd'hui comme tu peux en
témoigner. Je je valide et je je
certifie.
Merci. Mais c'est vrai que non, moi je
je dis ce que je pense simplement et
comme je l'ai vouqué tout à l'heure,
ça t'a coûté un peu quand même hein.
Ah oui oui, là ça m'a dernièrement ça
m'é
tu veux qu'on en parle maintenant ou
tout à l'heure par
comme tu veux. C'est toi qui est maître
de ton plan.
Écoute, tu veux qu'on en parle ? Moi si
moi j'ai justement j'ai j'ai dit j'en
parle pas trop de p je veux pas
je veux pas en parler
mais je me dis tiens je vais faire je
vais voir Sky peut-être l'occasion d'en
parler. Voilà, je je voulais en parler
sur ma chaîne également YouTube mais
j'en ai parlé un petit peu cette semaine
sur avec André Berkov sur Radio parce
que c'est vrai que
bon, je vais vous dire ce qui m'est
arrivé. Bon, il y a plein de trucs mais
notamment ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué,
c'est qu'il y a quelques mois donc mon
banquier m'appelle. Donc je suis dans
une banque, j'ai ouvert mon compte une
banque française, une grande banque
française.
J'avais 15 ans parce que bon, j'aimais
bien le tennis à l'époque et comme voilà
sponsorisé du tennis, alors je me dis oh
là là. Bref, et donc je dis bon, j'ai
ouvert mon compte il y a il y a donc
j'avais 15 ans, 16 ans, bref et j'ai
depuis j'ai toujours été à cette banque
et j'ai jamais eu un seul découvert.
J'ai jamais demandé un crédit à cette
banque parce que quand je travaillais
dans une autre banque, j'avais le crédit
dans mon autre banque dans laquelle je
travaillais mais j'ai quand même gardé
mon courte dans cette banque et cetera.
Bon bref et donc
banque de cœur
à banque de cœur et il y a quelques mois
donc là je suis même j'étais même à la
banque d'affaires, la banque privée, je
voulais pas mais bon et moi vous on est
obligé. Bon bref, très bien. Il
m'appelle un monsieur très gentil
d'ailleurs. Marc, écoutez, on est désolé
mais voilà, notre banque veut plus
travailler avec vous. Mais ça ça veut
dire quoi ? Je comprends pas. Ah bah
non. Ben voilà, on a pris la décision
mais ça veut dire quoi ? C'est c'est
quoi la raison ? Et ça, j'ai appris
quelque chose, tu vois, comme quoi on
apprend quelque chose, on apprend tous
les jours qu'en fait dans le droit
bancaire français, une banque peut
fermer tes comptes sans te donner de
raison.
C'est comme ça quand tu signes le
contrat en fait il y a un petit alinéa
voilà et peut fermer tes comptes et te
dire sans aucune raison. Donc moi j'ai
fait mon petit enquête quand même parce
que j'ai des amis dans cette banque et
ils sont revenus vers moi, ils m'ont dit
"Écoute Marc, ça vient de très haut."
Voilà son général.
Tu t'es fâché avec quelqu'un ? Il s'est
passé quelque chose ? Alors j'ai j'ai
fait j'ai regardé des virements de
Colombie.
Non non même pas même pas. Moi j'ai j'ai
jamais eu de cash dans mon dans dans mes
comptes.
Tuas financé des terroristes.
Non même pas. J'ai jamais eu de cash
dans mes comptes. Je je fais quasiment
pas de retrait de cash. Enfin bon, tu
vois donc et alors j'ai regardé les cas
parce qu'il y a des cas quand même. Donc
c'est effectivement trafic de drogue.
Bon, je me suis jamais drogué de ma vie
et puis j'ai jamais trafiqué. Donc c'est
pas moment maintenant que je vais
commencer. Euh c'est si tu as mal parlé
ou tu as insulté ton chargé de
clientèle,
ce qui est normal,
ce qui n'est mais non mais ça ça m'est
jamais arrivé non plus, tu vois. Et puis
je sais pas quoi, tu fais beaucoup de
retraits en espèce, je sais pas comment
des cas bon qui sont pas du tout les
miens. Moi alors moi je crois que
c'était une blague au départ. Donc ils
ont fermé le compte de ma boîte, mes
comptes perso, les comptes de mes
enfants,
tu vois. Non, je attends, c'est c'est un
truc de fou et tout ça. Bon, je je
j'imagine d'où ça vient, hein. Mais
c'est quand même, attendez, on est en
France, j'ai rien fait de mal, moi. Je
juste je dis la vérité, tu vois. J'ai ma
chaîne YouTube comme toi. C'està-dire
c'est vrai que on dérange quand on
réussit en France. On dérange, c'est
sûr. Et moi, je suis fier que beaucoup
de j'ai beaucoup de personnes qui me
disent "Moi, je je suivais pas
l'économie, grâce à vous, j'aime
l'économie, non, je m'y intéresse."
C'est formidable. Alors, peut-être ça
dérange et effectivement euh j'en arrive
à cela et donc je me dis c'est quand
même dramatique. Et donc je dis, je le
dis, je le dis pas. Bon, heureusement,
il y a d'autres banques en France donc
j'en ai j'en ai pris à d'autres qui qui
vont accepté parce que j'ai rien à me
reprocher. Mais je me dis, tu veux c'est
ça m'a fait de la peine parce que c'est
comme tu dis, c'est ma banque de cœur,
c'est-à-dire c'est une banque j'ai
depuis que je suis tout petit, tu vois.
Donc jamais j'aurais cru ça. Et surtout
que encore une fois, ils avaient de
l'argent qui dormaiit que je je
l'investissais même pas, je laissais de
l'argent dormir. Je devrais pas dire ça,
c'est pas bien mais quasiment dormir, on
va dire. Donc tu vois bon et voilà c'est
c'est l'arrêté mais c'est pas fini.
Tu vois peut-être pas le tu vois
peut-être le mal où il y en a pas. C'est
peut-être peut-être parce que tu avais
un tout petit compte et que av peut-être
pas envie de parler avec toi. Non non à
ce momentlà à ce momentlà bon ok ben tu
me dis bon on met plus à la banque
privée. Bon okok mais non ça se fait
pas. Jeis ça c'est et bon c'était en
plus tu pouvais même pas négocier
décision d'en haut
tu te rends compte où on en est
aujourd'hui.
Tu as même pas eu une boîte de chocolat.
Ah
rien non j'ai rien eu. J'ai rien eu.
J'ai rien eu. J'ai rien eu. Et surtout
le banquier m'a dit euh par contre ne le
dites à personne hein bien entendu. Donc
tu vois je vous conseille pas de le dire
parce que ça va faire euh bon je vais
pas donner le nom de la banque parce que
bon mais on peut-être on a pas compris
qui c'était mais bon mais toujours
est-il c'est quand même une très grande
banque française c'est pas dire c'est
pas une petite banque de quartier. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? C'est ça fait
de la peine parce que j'avais une autre
vision de cette banque également. J'ai
même eu à un moment des actions de cette
banque. Euh c'est triste, tu vois, de
dire de te dire "Tu as rien fait de mal
et et peut-être que les vrais
trafiquants, ils ont leur compte dans
cette banque, tu vois ? Et toi, on va
t'embêter." Non, non, là, c'est
suputation ça.
Oui. Oui. Non, mais façon de parler,
mais tu comprends, c'estàd que il y a
des gens qu'on va laisser tranquille
puis d'autres. Mais pourquoi ? Mo moi
j'aurais qu'il me disent voilà ben en
fait
ça dérange mais
l'histoire de Sarine pas là
c'est que quelques semaines plus tard
contrôle fiscal
sur ma boîte quelques semaines plus tard
encore contrôle fiscal perso
alors tu bon j'ai rien à me reprocher
mais
tuas un expert comptable
oui oui non non mais là je suis en train
je suis en plein dang je pense que ça va
bien se passer j'ai pas mais c'est c'est
ça ça te demande du temps on te demande
des notes de frais de 10
On te dit oui vous avez acheté des
costumes. Bah oui, j'ai acheté c'est
normal, j'ai le droit. Moi je pensais
j'avais un expert comptable.
C'est normal.
Non mais non on me dit non tu as pas le
droit d'acheter
non mais sur les notes de frais de 10 €
alors nous on a une exp de problème. Non
ça te prend du temps
chaque moindre petit ticket il faut
qu'on lui ramène que ce soit stocké. Ce
qui est difficile sur c'est que moi je
travaille 10h par jour depuis 30 ans. Tu
t'as acheté tu as acheté ton bleu de
travail.
Non non mais peu importe mais c'està
dire tu as pas que ça à faire mais c'est
bien. OK. Bon voilà
c'est normal. Oui, c'est normal. Mais
simplement cet acharnement qui fait qui
qui est incroyable. Et alors pour tout
te dire,
cet alignement des planètes, c'est
peut-être le hasard.
Ah ouais. Al là, tu es tu es gentil.
Non, mais il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres trucs également. C'est que
tu sais comment on dit alignement des
planètes ?
En quoi ? En quelle langue ?
En français.
Non, je sais pas. Dis-moi.
Siig.
Ah, c'est pas mal. C'est pas mal. Pas de
scrab.
Ouais, ouais. Non, non, non, mais ça tu
as raison. C'est si bien sûr, j'adore le
scrab. Bien sûr. Alors donc et donc
sachant que en toile de fond de tout ça,
alors d'ailleurs j'en profite pour le
dire aujourd'hui
et j'ai placé 50 points.
Ah ouais ouais c'est
c'est un truc que don la communauté.
Ah ouais effectivement c'est bien. Donc
non c'est bon pas de problème. Non mais
euh là je le dis j'en profite pour le
dire attention faites très attention
parce que depuis pareil depuis quelques
mois il y a un acharnement sur ma
personne sur internet avec des faux
comptes sur Facebook, sur Instagram, sur
WhatsApp et cetera. Donc on met à tête
même, on fait parler avec Lia, c'est
incroyable. On dit voilà achetez tel ou
tel produit, vous allez gagner de temps,
ce n'est pas moi. Je dis ce n'est pas
moi. Moi je fais aucun truc comme ça. Et
même j'ai même des amis qui me disent
"Mais qu'est-ce qui t'a pris de faire ?"
Non mais c'est ce n'est pas moi. Donc
faites attention. Et là, alors j'ai pris
un web master évidemment, un mec costaud
pour me dire
ouais webmre pour me dire "Ah, casse-moi
ça, quoi, arrête-moi ça." Donc au début,
il a réussi et là maintenant, il m'a
envoyé les messages de Facebook et
cetera qui me disent "On on peut pas
fermer les comptes parce que il y a il y
a quelqu'un audessus, on sait pas qui,
qui paye ses comptes, qui paye pour ses
comptes." Incroyable, tu vois,
tu as été posé plainte
bien sûr, mais j'ai été voir la police,
ils m'ont dit "On peut rien faire." Donc
là, ça y est,
avec la gendarmerie,
ouais, mais on peut rien, ils peuvent
rien faire. Ils m'ont dit "Bon, c'est
compliqué et je même pas je Bon bref et
euh et là bon là j'ai trouvé peut-être
un avocat justement qui est spécialiste
sur ça, peut-être qu'il va faire quelque
chose mais surtout je je veux que je je
veux que que les personnes qui m'aiment
bien n'aillent pas sur ça. C'est surtout
ça. Donc j'en profite pour effectivement
le dire et pour se ruire sur le contrôle
fiscal. La semaine dernière, je fais une
émission de téléradio bon, on va pas
donner de nom. Et je dis raconte mon
histoire au présentateur que je connais
depuis 30 ans où et il m'a dit c'est
incroyable m' arrivé la même chose. Il a
interviewé donc une grande personnalité
française qui va bientôt partir et euh
et donc ça s'est mal passé. Tu vois, il
est un peu titillé, il m'a dit 5 jours
plus tard, contrôle fiscal. Et lui, en
plus lui en plus il est que salarié. Tu
vois parce que non mais mais
c'est dans quelle société on vit ?
Mais c'est peut-être le hasard.
Non, arrête arrête. Non. Sky non, ça se
fait pas. C'est-à-dire, on n'est pas des
gens, on n'est pas des trafiquants, tu
comprends ? Nous, on veut simplement
sauver notre pays. En tout cas, en ce
qui me concerne, moi je veux que mon
pays s'en sorte. Je j'ai des recettes
pour que mon pays s'en sorte. Pourquoi
on m'attaque ? Pourquoi on m'embête ?
C'est pas une attaque, c'est qui te
contrôle.
Non, non, d'accord. Non, mais la banque
la banque la banque la banque. Faut
arrêter de faut arrêter d'exagérer. Faut
exagérer. Alors, je vais terminer par un
truc qui m'arrive la semaine dernière
incroyable aussi sur ce point. On
continuera, je pense. Ah ouais, non, je
va je vais le raconter parce que ça ça
c'est c'est inadmissible.
Pas de diffamation, pas d'énigrement.
Ah, je peux pas donner le nom. Alors
bon, alors je donne pas le nom. Bon,
bref, la semaine dernière, il y a un
grand organisme
français qui a organisé donc une une
grande conférence. Tout ça, c'est les
universités d'été.
Le MEDF,
tu m'as dit de rien dire. Alors,
tu me dis de rien dire. Je sais pas. Je
vois pas. Je vois
tu me dis de rien dire. Moi je sais pas.
Alors moi je je dis rien. Tu dis bon.
Bah tu as les preuves.
Ah bien sûr.
D'accord.
J'ai même les naîtres parce que son
président que je connais parce que
j'interviens régulièrement dans dans
faire des conférence. Voilà, il y a il y
a pas de mal hein. Je pour tout le monde
ceux qui me demandent bref et euh qui me
payent aussi parce que sinon à part ici
là je suis pas payé là je suis pas payé.
Non non mais là peu importe.
Quand tu veux savoir combien combien on
paye pour une conférence pour une
conférence moi en fait moi je je suis
transparent mais conf je suis pas très
cher hein.
Et puis en plus c'est déclaré
bien sûr. Ah ben évidemment conférence
c'est 4500 € hors taxe. Voilà.
pour tout le monde c'est après les taxes
à peu près il 2005 après les taxes.
Ouais voilà. Non non les taxes c'est
au-dessus la TVA quoi. La TVA c'est en
plus quand même. Mais bon toujours que
voilà c'est mais je suis pas cher quand
tu prends d'autres qui sont évidemment
qui qui exagèrent. Par contre là où je
non mais je préfère le dire. Tu as
raison il faut le dire parce que la
dernière l'année dernière je suis tombé
je fais une conférence comme ça et le le
le c'était un un organisme
je crois une fédération du de dans la
construction. Bref, et le président m'a
adoré donc il voulait absolument que ça
soit moi qui vienne. Mais il savait pas
qu'on pouvait m'avoir en direct.
D'ailleurs, je le dis, vous pouvez
m'avoir en direct si vous le souhaitez
évidemment. Et euh donc il est passé par
l'intermédiaire. Bon et donc je fais la
conférence, tout se passe très bien et
cetera et le président après me dire "Ah
merci beaucoup, j'espère mais je voulais
quand même vous dire vous êtes quand
même très cher." Je dis "Ah bon trouvez
? Ben non 4500 € quoi Il dit 4000 au
mois j'ai payé trois fois ça
j'ai payé bon 13000 crois tu imagines
donc le mec donc l'intermédiaire
je crois même qu'il y en avait deux
10 chasseurs de talent
non mais tu te rends compte donc moi
j'ai été
on s'en fout
non mais tu as compris le truc non mais
c'est faut dire les choses mais bon
reviens reviens bah il faut il
Ah ouais non mais il faut pas exagérer
tu chacun prend sa marge mais là faut
pas exagérer. Bref, donc voilà donc je
le dis si vous voulez que je fasse des
conférences donc voilà donc ce grand
organisme et cetera donc son président
me voit on se voit justement à la sortie
d'une émission de télé je sais pas quand
je crois que c'était BFM au mois de juin
il me dit écoute Marc je vais comme toi
tu tu remues tu remues un peu les les
codes et cetera donc on a besoin j'ai
besoin de toi je veux que tu
interviennes pour notre université d'été
pour que nous dise comment on sauve la
France avec plaisir d'accord donc
ah si maman était encore là elle serait
fière Non, maman était très fière déjà
il y a longtemps parce qu'elle est
partie malheureusement en 2004, tu vois.
Donc j'étais encore j'étais un petit
bébé encore à l'époque.
Mais euh mais euh voilà. Et donc euh
très bien. Donc ils font de la pub, ils
mettent ma photo, ils annoncent, ils
envoient des invitations avec ma photo,
tout ça. Marc bon très bien. En plus, le
pire c'est que pour tout te dire, j'ai
même dû un petit peu avancer mon retour
de vacances. C'était le 28 août et je
devais rentrer un petit peu plus tard.
Bon bref, finalement, heureusement que
j'étais là parce que vu ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière, bon
heureusement, on a eu besoin de moi.
Mais bon, toujours est-il que le 27,
donc moi je j'avais noté, tu vois, mais
je me souvenais plus de l'heure exacte.
Donc j'envoie un message euh à quelle
heure j'interviens demain ? On me répond
"On est désolé mais on a changé le
programme.
Ils m'ont enlevé de la de la de enfin de
du programme et sachant qu'il y avait je
devis faire un débat avec une autre
économiste on pas don à la pauvre chérie
et elle ils l'ont maintenu dans un autre
débat." Bref, je dis c'est un
truc de fou quand même.
Ils ont peut-être tu eu un empêchement
ils ont
Non mais attends c'est grave. Bah c'est
peut-être tu vois le mal donc je leur ai
envoyé un message pour leur dire écoutez
c'est quand même très grave ce que vous
faites. J'ai même envoyé un message
sur WhatsApp au président pas de réponse
même pas d'excuses. Ils veulent ils
veulent plus m'entendre parce que
quelqu'un a dit non si toi tu viens moi
je viens pas. Oh rigueur appelle-moi.
Tiens c'est comme j'étais pas j'étais en
vacances mais j'avais mon téléphone qui
marchait. J'ai pas comme Byou ils
étaient en vacances ils peuvent
m'appeler. Le téléphone ça existe.
Et nous on t'a ennuyé pendant tes
vacances. Alors voilà, toi même tu m'as
sollicité, je t'ai répondu. Voilà, donc
c'est c'est quoi ? C'est quoi ces
méthodes ? Donc ça commence à faire
beaucoup. Donc c'est clair que je
dérange. La bonne nouvelle c'est que je
dérange. Ça veut dire que je suis dans
le vrai. C'estd que ce que nous faisons,
nous sommes dans la vérité. Et et je
suis optimiste parce que je suis
persuadé qu'on va s'en sortir. Je suis
persuadé qu'un jour, peut-être pas tout
de suite, peut-être, peut-être tout de
suite, on sait pas, peut-être bientôt et
bien on va réussir à sauver la France.
Tu vois, tu as des points commun avec
François Berou.
À quel niveau ? Bah, il est persuadé
qu'on va réussir.
Ah ben oui, mais lui non. En tout cas,
lui, il réussira pas parce qu'il va
partir là bientôt. Mais non, mais encore
une fois,
pas sûr.
Ah si quand même. Mais je veux dire,
c'est que pour réussir, il faut euh il
faut de l'abnégation. Il faut dire
voilà, je je pense qu'au français, moi
je te l'ai dit tout à l'heure, moi
l'argent c'est pas ce qui compte. Moi je
pourrais presque m'arrêter de travailler
parce que je vois, je veux aider mes
enfants, mes petits enfants maintenant
tu l'as dit, et puis je veux profiter de
la vie. Je je suis encore jeune, j'ai
que 55 ans, c'est jeune. Revenons
mais bon, toujours est-il que
voilà, tu vois, je je j'étais pas sûr
que j'allais le dire, mais ça fait ça
m'a fait du bien de le dire.
Ça fait du bien de vider son sac.
Non, mais c'est dire en Non, qu'est-ce
que tu en penses ? Franchement Sky,
je suis pas là pour penser, je suis là
pour poser des questions.
Non, mais je suis d'accord mais c'est
quand même incroyable. C'est quand même
incroyable dans un pays comme la France
où quelqu'un qui fait un économiste, ça
fait moi ce qui dérange,
c'est le hasard. Non, ce qui les
dérange, je vais te dire, c'est que moi,
ça fait 30 ans que j'ai ce métier, ça
fait 30 ans que je suis là. Donc,
tu as la légitimité.
Voilà. Donc, les gens savent que et que
et que je suis là depuis 30 ans. Donc,
si je suis là depuis 30 ans et puis pour
te dire, on m'en a fait des des parce
que ça c'est on a fait des autres coups
de crass hein. Combien de fois une fois,
j'ai eu un ministre qui m'a appelé en me
disant "Ouais, je vais vous faire virer
de la Texis parce que vous avez dit dans
la presse, ça m'a pas plu." Un président
même. Listé d'une grande émission de
télé, un président, tu vois, pour te
dire que je faisais beaucoup à l'époque.
Bon, j'ai eu des trucs comme ça, tu
vois. Bon et tu vois, c'est là où je
quand même je je veux je veux dire merci
quand même à Bruno Lemire parce que
pendant quand il était ministre
d'économie, j'ai été le voir plusieurs
fois et puis je le titis quand même. que
j'ai dit même des fois j'étais peut-être
presque méchant avec lui mais il m'a
jamais fait ce truc de coup ce type de
de coup là depuis le début d'année comme
par hasard il vous mise de l'économie
vos premier ministre non mais c'est
bizarre comme par hasard il m'a bam tu
vois j'ai j'ai même dit si tu veux au
aux inspecteurs des impôts j' dit c'est
qui sont d'ailleurs en général
qui sont très bien mais mon mais mon
père travaillait aux impôts. Moi-même
j'ai travaillé aux impôts quand j'étais
jeune. Je faisais mes stages d'été aux
impôts. Tu vois pour te dire il y a il y
a pas de saut métier c'est très bien.
C'est des gens très gentils et je leur
ai dit "Vous savez, je comprends que ça
vient de d'en haut." Elle me dit "On
peut rien vous dire. Nous effectivement
ça arrive, on a le dossier arrive, on
doit on doit le traiter." Mais je vous
il y a pas de problème, je comprends
très bien.
Tu es pas tombé dans les dans les
grilles de l'algorithme pour repérer les
grands délinquants ?
Mais pourquoi là ? J'ai rien fait là si
tu veux entre le mois de janvier et
voilà. J'ai rien fait. Non mais bon, on
va pas on va pas euh d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs juste termine sur ça. Je
voudrais je voudrais remercier quand
même.
Non, je suis pas du tout suicidaire.
Non. D'ailleurs maintenant tu tu as
remarqué je commence mes vidéos toutes
mes vidéos maintenant sur ma chaîne
YouTube en disant deux choses. D'abord
je rappelle la la phrase de Georgewell
dans 1984 dans un dans une phase de
supercherie universelle. Dire la vérité
est un acte révolutionnaire. Donc nous
faisons la révolution Jaska et moi-même
et d'autres bien entendu tant mieux. Et
je rappelle en dessous je ne suis pas
suicidaire parce qu'on sait jamais tu
tout ce que je dis. Bon ben voilà et
j'espère voilà mais pour tout dire après
en plus bon je pas entrer dans l'état
mais j'ai dit justement aux inspecteurs
maf des problèmes de santé enfin même
des gros problèmes santé c cet été et
cetera je allz me dire ok on vous laisse
tranquille pas du tout bon ok on vous
laisse un petit un petit délai c'est
incroyable ça ça fait mal ça tu vois
c'est dire
si tu arrivrive des bricoles avoir une
bière sur ta tombou ouais non mais
j'espère pas qu'il en arrivent des
bricoles j'espère que vivre encore au
moins 30 ans. Tu riges ? J'ai envie de
voir la France sortir de l'ornière quand
même.
Reven
revenons à la France.
Ouais.
Ce côté choc économique, ce côté
stackflation qui commence à mordre.
Tiens, tu veux pas une fois que tu as
fini ta gorgée,
c'est quoi la stag flation marque ?
Ah ben c'est très simple. Stack flation
ça veut dire stag c'est stagnation
économique. Flation c'est inflation
élevée. Parce qu'en fait en temps normal
quand tu as de l'inflation tu as une
bonne croissance. Pourquoi ? Parce que
ce qu'on appelle l'inflation par la
demande. Comme tu as une croissance qui
est forte donc ça veut dire que tu as
une demande qui est forte donc bah la
demande supérieure à l'offre c'est une
règle de base de l'économie. Les prix
montent donc l'inflation monte. Mais ça
c'est de la bonne inflation si tu veux.
Par contre ça s'est produit avec le
premier choc pétrolier et puis le second
encore pire. Puis dernièrement
également, c'est que quand tu as un choc
exogène, par exemple un choc pétrolier
ou l'augmentation des cours des matières
premières, voilà, lié à après à la
guerre la guerre en Ukraine, à ce
moment-là, tu as effectivement
l'inflation qui augmente mais pas à
cause de ta demande. Elle augmente parce
que c'est exogène, ça vient de
l'étranger, par exemple, à cause du
pétrole qui flambe, tu vois. Donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe si l'inflation
augmente ? Le pouvoir d'achat baisse, tu
vois. Donc tu as moins de consommation,
donc moins d'investissement, donc plus
de chômage et la récession. Donc c'est
que
et là bien sûr donc tu as à la fois
l'inflation et la stagnation économique,
tu vois stagflation donc c'est c'est
évidemment extrêmement dangereux. C'est
ce qu'on a connu notamment euh pendant
après la guerre en Ukraine qu'on a connu
lors des premiers seconds choc
pétroliers et ce qu'on risque de
reconnaître maintenant parce que
l'inflation n'a pas disparu. Tu vois
elle redémarre un petit peu. Tu as
également tous les droits de douane au
niveau mondial il y aura des
répercussions. Donc on parle aux
États-Unis mais c'est pas que aux
États-Unis. Ça va jouer là aussi au
niveau mondial. Et ce qui veut dire que
tu peux avoir à la fois une inflation
élevée et une et une récession
économique. Et si effectivement tu as
une inflation élevée, le problème c'est
que quand l'inflation est élevée, les
banques centrales, elles peuvent pas
baisser leur taux d'intérêt, donc elles
peuvent pas relancer la machine.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, je vais
m'adresser à ceux qui sont sur notre
IRC. Faites monter les questions les
plus intéressantes avec des petits
pouces ou des petites choses comme ça
qu'on puisse tomber directement sur ce
qui vous intéresse à poser comme
question à Marc. Revenons à Revenons à
nos moutons. Marc
qui comment l'Europe l'Europe au milieu
de tout ça, la France à l'intérieur de
l'Europe, la guerre économique qu'on est
en train de se prendre du côté
américain, du côté chinois, du côté on
est au milieu du gay. Euh l'euro
est-elle une monnaie fantôme euh basée
sur que des belles paroles et de la
belle chat parce queon n' pas de
ressources économique autre que notre
bonne bouille. Euh euh on n' pas de
ressources en matière première. Est-ce
que tu crains pour l'euro ? Je crains
pour l'Europe, bien sûr. L'Europe
au-delà de l'euro, bien sûr. L'euro,
bien entendu, la zone euro. Encore une
fois, ce qui est en train de se dessiner
aujourd'hui, on le voit bien, les
Américains vont s'entendre avec les
Chinois, avec les Indiens, ils vont
trouver des accords parce
qu'effectivement, c'est les c'est des
partenaires commerciaux, c'est des
partenaires financiers en terme de dette
publique notamment. Donc, ils vont
réussir à s'entendre. Par contre, le
Don,
c'est pas sûr, hein,
tu verras, ils s'entendront. Il y a un
panier de côté des Chinois, des bricks.
Mais les Chinois, encore une fois, je
t'ai exqué tout à l'heure, eux ils ont
compris, ils ont raison. Moi, moi je ça
fait très longtemps effectivement, j'ai
vu des dirigeants chinois à l'époque en
en 2000, tu vois, pour te dire. J'avais
la chance justement à Texis à l'époque,
j'avais rencontré le patron de la Bank
of China. C'est un ancien général
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
généraux dans les banques là-bas. Donc,
ça change de
c'est le hasard aussi.
C'est le hasard aussi. Et donc, il
m'avait dit quelque chose qui m'avait
marqué. Il m'a dit "Vous savez, monsieur
Platti enfin dans un anglais
approximatif parce qu'effectivement bon
bref mais bon il se débrouillit bien
quand même parce que je parle pas
chinois je vous rassure." Et donc il me
disait euh la Chine a toujours été la
première puissance mondiale. Alors je
regarde vous êtes sûr ? Il oui non mais
c'est vrai il y a eu quelques siècles de
pause
un seul. Voilà. Mais maintenant, on va
reprendre notre rôle, reprendre notre
place. Et c'est vrai que c'était un
petit peu, je dis bon, c'est du
marketing. Effectivement, c'est vrai, tu
l'as bien dit, dans les années 1800, la
Chine était la première puissance
mondiale. Après, il y a eu le la grande
parenthèse effectivemento et cetera.
Bon,
siècle de la honte à
Exactement, tout à fait. Et et ensuite
effectivement là, ils sont en train de
reprendre leur place. Mais si quand tu
regardes le niveau parce que aujourd'hui
en terme de PIB effectivement, les
Chinois sont encore derrière les
Américains. Payb en dollars courant. Si
tu regardes en ce qu'on appelle en
parité de pouvoir d'achat, ça veut dire
en retraitant avec les pouvoirs d'achat,
en mettant une main pouvoir d'achat
entre les États-Unis et la Chine, et
bien là la Chine est devant les
États-Unis. C'est déjà la première
puissance mondiale, tu vois. Par contre,
effectivement, en terme de PIB par
habitant, là, ils ont encore du mal à se
développer. Et donc, la force de la
Chine, c'est quoi ? Donc, c'est ce qu'il
m'avait dit à l'époque, parce que
j'avais osé lui parler de démocratie et
cetera. Il m'avait dit "On est tout à
fait conscient de cela." C'était sympa
parce que c'était d'ailleurs c'était en
France, il était en France et il m'avait
dit euh on est conscient de cela mais
nous notre modèle c'est le
développement. Ça veut dire
le bonheur pour tous
presque. Dis en fait nous on est
conscient que si on développe le niveau
de vie des Chinois et ben ils
accepteront finalement le manque de
démocratie ou le manque de liberté
d'expression et cetera. Et c'est vrai
que ça a bien marché jusqu'à
dernièrement parce que en Chine, il y a
2000, il y avait à peu près 100 millions
de Chinois qui vaient correctement sur
1,4 milliards d'habitants. Là
maintenant, ils sont 700 millions à peu
près à vivre comme nous, comme des
Européens. C'est pas mal. Il manque
encore 700 millions qui attendent. Tu
vois donc la clé pour la Chine, c'est
dire est-ce que ces 700 millions qui
attendent, ils vont prendre le train et
le corona gestion du corona qu'ils en
ont fait a fait beaucoup de mal parce
qu'ils ont vraiment enfermé les gens.
Castrophique. Donc ça laissé des traces.
et notamment la Chine a perdu beaucoup
de part de marché vis-à-vis de l'Inde,
tu vois, il arrive pas à les récupérer.
Donc c'est pourquoi maintenant ils font
du dumping, ils vendent leurs produits
effectivement à à bas prix pour essayer
d'inonder d'inonder le monde. Et on voit
bien ce qui s'est passé derrièrement.
Trump a mis des droits de douan
vis-à-vis des produits chinois. Il est
moins que prévu mais il en a quand même
mis alors que nous on en a pas mis. Donc
que font les Chinois ? Il disent bah bon
on va moins exporter vers les États-Unis
mais on va peut-être plus exporter vers
d'autres pays notamment l'Europe
notamment la France parce que il y a pas
de droit de douan donc on y va. C'est
même pire que ça parce que les Français
acceptent des produits chinois qui alors
que ils n'ont pas les normes qu'on
impose au producteur français.
On accepte bien des œufs ukrainiens.
Ben pareil, c'est exactement le problème
problème pour nos agriculteurs. C'est
inadmissible.
Le mercour, ça te parle ?
Ouais, bien sûr. Bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Encore une fois, c'est ce sont des
accords commerciaux. Après, est-ce que
du gagnant gagnant ? Pas forcément. Mais
c'est clair que si tu fais un accord
commercial, tu dois avoir les mêmes
règles. Tu peux dire "On va accepter vos
produits mais qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes queon impose au producteurs
français. Ça ça ça peut pas coller, tu
vois. Donc il faut effectivement être de
ce point de vue là sur un pied
d'égalité.
S'il y a la défiance, s'il y a pas le
vote de confiance envers François Berou,
les agence de notation, je je pense que
elles vont dire quand même c'est un pays
qui n'a pas la du moins un gouvernement
qui n'a pas la confiance du peuple et
c'est compliqué pour pouvoir ensuite
dans l'avenir.
Bah c'est clair. Mais est-ce que est-ce
que tu penses pas que François, il a
déclenché ce vote de confiance pour
justifier la baisse de la de la de la
note française en disant voilà bah les
partis politiques ils m'ont pas ils ont
pas voté pour moi, c'est précipité
effectivement. J'ai pensé aussi c'estàd
je me suis dit parce que une bourde
pareil c'est quand même pas possible.
C'est dire que le fait de dire on va
demander un vote de confiance, je sais
très bien que tu as pas du tout la
majorité parce que je te rappelle que le
vote de confiance ça peut-être les
Français ne le savent pas, c'est pas la
majorité absolue, c'est la majorité des
présents, tu vois. Donc ça veut dire que
vu l'état de l'Assemblée, il a quasiment
aucune chance d'avoir un vote de
confiance donc excédentaire, tu vois.
Euh mais donc c'est suicidaire, c'est
arquiri, tu vois. Donc pourquoi l'a-t-il
fait ? Alors après, je me dis
peut-être pour laisser son nom dans
l'histoire comme quoi c'est un premier
ministre qui a dit la vérité au
français. Bon, peut-être un peu tard.
Non, mais encore une fois, non mais il a
pas dit la vérité aux français. Quand il
a dit la hausse de la dette publique,
c'est à cause des Français. Ah non, mais
c'est pas la vérité ça.
Cre sa vérité. Ah non, mais là là je
pense que tu vois et euh justement que
un de ses conseillers, enfin j'ai fait
un débat il y a pas longtemps, un de ses
amis même près, il m'a dit "Vous verrez,
il va euh il va il va il va il va faire
le tout pour le tout, il va il va faire
vraiment des euh des vraies réformes et
cetera." Ouais.
Euh ben c'était pas le cas, tu vois.
C'estàd que à la rigueur si il dit "Je
vais faire la thérapie de choc
bienveillante", à ce moment-là, OK, bon,
il s'en va. Mais là, c'est même pas le
cas. Il te dit "Ouais, je vais faire 40
milliards d'économie mais euh j'augmente
mes dépenses de 30 milliards." Elle elle
est où le est elle est où la thérapie de
choc ? Elle est où ?
Non, tu es gentil, tu as compris ? Non,
c'est pas ce n'est pas sérieux. Encore
une fois, je le redis. Tu vois, tu
as même pas emmené un t-shirt pour
Non, j'aurais dû j'ai pas pensé,
excuse-moi. Non, mais tu sais pourquoi
j'ai dit je fais ce t-shirt ? Parce que
dire, vous êtes vendeur de t-shirt ça
moi ça ça me revient, tu vois. Les
stchlm ça revient quand même, tu vois.
Ça c'est bon. Bref, non pas du tout.
C'est parce qu' comme je dis souvent
fier
mais oui bien sûr mais j'en suis très
fier de M d'Orly d'ailleurs je
l'aéroport sais que quand j'ai atterri à
Orlie je vois je vois mon immeuble
encore je vois pas pas toujours. Ça
dépend comment on atterrit mais je le
vois encore. Bref c'est pour l'anecdote
mais donc tout le monde dit ST vous dit
tout le temps ce n'est pas sérieux donc
faites un t-shirt. Donc je dis ouais
c'est c'est une bonne idée. Mais moi
j'ai fait ça en rigolant et
effectivement ça a très bien marché.
J'ai même dû relancer une production
mais bon je vous rassure je suis pas
vendeur de t-shirt mais si vous le
mettez c'est pour justement
faire prendre conscience à nos
dirigeants que vous êtes conscient de la
gravité de la situation.
Oui. Puis vous pouvez voter aussi.
Ah oui aussi. Bah ça ça serait bien.
Euh
tu m'as coupé là-bas la chic. Euh
revenons revenons à
Non mais ouais on parlait
d'effectivement de Bairou justement où
Oui. Donc les contrebudgets
donc moi je te dis qu'effectivement moi
c'est une solution qu'en fait peut-être
qu'il a l'info qui que la note de la
France va être dégradée parce que en
fait même s'il avait fait passer son
enfin fait voter son budget on aurait vu
la motion de de défiance et donc on
aurait vu que c'était pas voté tu la la
motion de censure donc il aurait quand
même été dégradé. Donc peut-être que là
il dit bah voilà je suis dégradé à cause
de ça parce que vous m'avez pas donné la
confiance. Peut-être tu vois mais bon
c'est maavélique quand tu vois c'est pas
ce qu'on attend des dirigeants
politiques.
Le contre les contrebudgets qui ont été
présentés. Tuas tu as mis un peu ton nez
dedans ? Tu acheté ou
Oui, je t'ai dis j'ai vu le celui du PS
notamment. Bon ils sont il est quand
même
Ils y croient.
Ouais. Ouai ils y croient. Mais c'est
c'est c'est euh c'est c'est comment dire
? C'est utopique.
Mais alors c'est utopique parce que
c'est Alice au pays des merveilles.
Non c'està dire que en fait si tu veux
le problème c'est très simple. C'est ce
qu'a fait l'erreur même erreur que
François Hollande. Je me rappelle
d'ailleurs, je l'avais dit mais il avait
pas aimé et c'est que ils te disent
voilà il y a 100 de revenus, je monte
les impôts, on va dire de de 10 % ça va
me ramener 10 % des 100. Ben non, parce
que si j'augmente mes impôts, mon taux
d'imposition, je casse l'activité
économique, donc je réduis l'assiette
fiscale. Donc je ponctionne plus mais
sur un gâteau plus petit. Donc à la fin,
j'aurai moins de recettes fiscale. C'est
ce qu'on apprend en première année
d'économie. parce que c'est c'est du bé
à bas. C'est ce qu'on appelle aussi la
coupe de l'affaire. C'est trop d'impôt
tu l'impôts. C'est encore une fois c'est
du bon sens. Surtout que nous sommes en
France comme nous sommes déjà numéro 1
du monde des impôts. C'est tu étais dans
un pays qui avait pas d'impôts. Bon en
Grèce il y a quelques années. OK mais là
nous sommes déjà il y a pas il y a pas
pire. Quand c'était là aussi il a fait
une grave erreur B quand il a dit que
l'Italie faisait du dumping vis-à-vis de
nous.
C'est faire monter les br.
Oui. Non mais encore une fois comme la
France est numéro 1 du monde des impôts
ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que
tous les autres pays par rapport à nous
sont des paradis fiscaux parce qu'il y a
moins d'impôt que chez nous, tu vois.
Donc c'est
le Portugal c'est combien ?
Il y a bah à quel niveau tu veux dire ?
Au niveau de
la pose sur le revenu ?
La pose sur le revenu c'est en fait si
tu veux moi ce que je compare c'est plus
macroéconomiquement parlant. Il y a que
là effectivement en France on est autour
des 47 % au Portugal on est sous les 40.
Donc tu as pas tu as parlé euh du du de
du contrebudget socialiste, tu as étudié
quel
alors non alors j'ai vu également celui
du RN pour tout te dire et c'est vrai
que alors ça au pays des merveilles
alors sur un seul point où oui c'est la
retraite parce que là étud on revient à
72 ans mais ça m'a surpris c'est
qu'effectivement ils ont ils essayent de
se muscler un petit peu économiquement
ah oui non c'està dire parce que c'était
leur grand point faible il faut le dire
faut être honnête je veux dire point de
vue économique bon il y avait il y avait
pas grand monde. Et là, il commence
justement euh à essayer de Alors,
justement pour tout te dire, j'ai fait
un un débat avec un d'entre eux il y a
quelques jours, il a dit "Oui, euh si on
supprime les euh euh comment dire les
aides sur l'immigration, c'est 60
milliards d'euros." Mard d'euros, c'est
beaucoup, non ? C'est plutôt 15 à 20. Et
là, euh hier justement, j'ai fait avec
un autre du représentant, il m'a dit
"Non, c'est 18 milliards, donc tu vois,
il se calme, tu vois." Donc voilà. Par
contre, c'est sûr que
même si on peut réduire bien sûr
certaines dépenses, mais il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin. Donc déjà ce qui est
bien, c'est qu'ils veulent pas augmenter
les impôts, ça c'est déjà pas mal et ils
veulent baisser certaines dépenses. Mais
le problème, c'est le financement de la
retraite où là on y arrive pas. 62 ans,
comment tu fais ? Et là tout le problème
est là, c'est que c'est encore une fois
la retraite par répartition française de
la France, ce que j'appelle le système
Madof
pyramide de Ponzi.
Oui, en fait c'est très simple. Comment
ça marche ? C'est que quand tu es actif,
donc tu cotises mais pas pour ta
retraite. Tu cotises pour payer les
actuels retrait en espérant que quand
toi tu seras à la retraite, il y aura
assez d'actifs pour payer ta retraite.
Et on sait très bien que ça sera pas le
cas parce que ça ça marche tant qu'il y
a assez d'actifs par rapport au
retraiter. Donc jusqu'aux années 70 80,
il y avait à peu près 3,5 actifs pour un
retraité, ça marchait. Aujourd'hui, on
est à 1,4 actifs pour en retraiter. Donc
faut pas être grand clair ou grand
mathématicien pour comprendre que ça
marche pas. Tu peux pas financer ta
retraite. Alors dans la fonction
publique, c'est pire parce que là tu as
plus de retraités que d'actifs. Donc là
aussi, il y a il y a un mensonge
incroyable. On te dit la retraite ça
coûte cher, c'est x milliard d'euros et
cetera. Non mais ce qui compte c'est pas
combien ça coûte. Ce qui compte, c'est
le est-ce qu'il y a un déficit ou pas
des retraites. Et alors là, attention,
sur le régime privé, pour l'instant, ça
va peut-être pas durer, mais pour
l'instant, il n'y a pas de déficit des
retraites. Où est-ce qu'il y a un
déficit ? C'est sur la retraite de la
fonction publique, entre 60 et 80
milliards d'euros par an. Alors, tu
vois, l'arnaque, c'est qu'on te dit "Ah
mais c'est pas un déficit puisque
effectivement les fonctionnaires ne
côtisent pas. C'est c'est un système
différent." Donc c'est l'État qui fait
ce qu'on appelle une sur euh cotisation
de lui-même. C'est une sorte de
subvention si tu veux. Donc il dit c'est
pas un déficit, c'est une subvention.
Oui, mais d'où vient l'argent ? Bah oui,
80 milliards d'euros, hein. Il tombe pas
il tombe pas du ciel, tu comprends ?
Donc c'est ça qui fait qu'on a
aujourd'hui cette retraite justement du
système public qui n'est pas du tout
financé. Et donc c'est là où là encore
une fois, on trompe les Français. Et moi
aussi, j'ai pesté quand euh François
Baou justement a dit euh "Ah bah oui,
c'est à cause des boomers et cetera."
Bon, faut arrêter ça aussi, nous
l'oublions pas. Alors, les boomers,
c'est quoi ? C'est ceux qui sont nés
dans les années, on va dire euh voilà,
après la lors de l'après-guerre
46, c'est ça.
Ouais. Voilà. Ouais, peut-être un peu
avant même parce que quand tu es né en
65, je suis désolé, tu es rentré sur
marché du travail, c dans les années 80,
donc c'était en plein deuxème choc pété,
donc tu as pas connu, tu as connu la
crise, moi je suis n 70, moi je suis un
enfant de la crise, tu vois. Alors après
c encore pire mais toujours est-il que
c'est c'est très peu les les personnes
qui ont profité vraiment des des tr
glorieuses. C'est très peu. Puis surtout
les 30 glorieuses c'était quoi ? C'est
qu'il y avait une croix en sorte mais
surtout les gens bossaient. Tu avais tu
avais pas les 35 heur à l'époque tu
avais pas
infession de dingue aussi.
Tu une infection alors ça dépendait mais
comme tu avais une croissance forte ça
compensait. Tu vois ce qui compte
effectivement c'est la croissance c'est
l'activité économique. Tu avais
effectivement un chômage qui était
faible donc ça allait encore tu vois.
Mais c'est là où c'est très important de
le dire. Euh les boomers comme on les
appelle, bah ils ont cotisé toute leur
vie. Donc tu peux pas leur dire "Ah ben
maintenant que tu es arrivé à la
retraite, on va pas te payer." Ça c'est
comme si tu tu as une une assurance
voiture et on te dit bah tu as eu un
accident, bah alors bah non mais il y a
pas assez d'argent, je rembourse pas tes
tes frais de sur la voiture. Ben oui
mais j'ai cotisé. Comment c'est une
sorte d'assurance tu vois ? Donc par
contre est-ce que certains ont pas
profité ? Oui, notamment justement dans
la haute fonction publique. Ah oui, bien
entendu, il y a eu il y a eu des abuss,
c'est sûr. Mais ça ça fait moi ça me
fait peur ce discours parce que ça veut
dire quoi ? Alors quoi ? Tu veux que les
retraités soient pauvres ? N'oublie pas
que Mais n'oublie pas que ils sont déjà
pauvres. La moitié effectivement des
retraités gagnent moins que le SMIC.
C'est ça qui est très
dangulteur. C'est c'est
exactement. Et surtout quand tu es
retraité aujourd'hui, ça d'ailleurs je
le dis à nos auditeurs, faites très
attention parce que vous votre revenu va
baisser et donc pour beaucoup de
retraités
pense que ça va baisser.
Ah c'est sûr. Ben déjà c'est de facto
parce qu'on a pas le même niveau et là
aussi il y a une injustice parce que
dans la dans le secteur privé on prend
les 25 25 meilleures années et dans la
fonction publique on prend les 6
derniers mois pour quelques donc c'est
pas pareil.
Et donc juste pour terminer, c'est que
si tu retraite justement encore une fois
attention malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui sont à la
limite qui sont dans la classe moyenne
et quand ils tombent à la retraite s'ils
sont pas propriétaires de leur logement
avec le loyer et cetera, ils tombent
dans la pauvreté tu vois. Donc moi je
trouve ça presque inadmissible si tu
veux que de la part d'un premier
ministre tu pointes du doigt une
catégorie de la population. un un
dirigeant français, premier ministre,
président, il est garantité
sociale, sociétale. Il doit protéger
tous les Français. Il doit pas liguer
les uns contre les autres.
Donc si je te résume euh je parle sous
ton contrôle, euh on va avoir on a'ura
pas de retraite. Non,
on en aura quand même et pas beaucoup.
On aura des des une retraite en rou 800
sans sonnet.
C'est pourquoi un conseil que je donne,
préparez votre retraite. C'est pourquoi
on dit pourquoi les Français épargnent ?
Bah oui, ils épargnent parce que
justement ils ont peur pour leur
retraite, ils ont peur pour leur vieux
jour,
ils épargnent en euros, c'est ça ?
Mais ils épartent en ce qu'ils peuvent,
ils ce qu' peuvent.
Et donc tu sais que les argentins, ils
épargnent avec du plac plâtre parce
qu'il y avait tellement d'inflation que
comme ils avaient pas d'argent pour
acheter des actions ou acheter de l'or
ou acheter de l'argent physique ou pas
physique,
bah ils achetaient du Corex ou du
placoplâre placoplâtre pour stocker leur
pouvoir d'achat contre l'inflation. Bon,
revenons à nos moutons. On se retrouve,
on aura pas de retraite, on a une
pyramide des âges qui euh qui marche sur
la tête. Ah oui, ça d'ailleurs sur ça,
un élément très important, je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu, je l'ai évoqué dans
une vidéo il y a quelques mois.
Incroyable.
C'est ça. Ça fait froid dans le dos.
C'est la première fois que ça arrive
dans l'histoire de France. Le taux de
natalité est passé sous le taux de
mortalité. Il y a 9,4
décès pour 1000 habitants, 9,2 naissance
pour 1000 habitants. On n jamais vu ça.
Donc ça ça c'est très inquiétant parce
que attention euh là tu es en train
quand la population commence à baisser,
ça veut dire que ton pays est en train
de mourir. Donc pourquoi évidemment les
Français ne font pas d'enfants ? C'est
parce qu'ils ont peur de l'avenir, tu
vois, notamment les jeunes, tu vois. Et
évidemment et puis en plus quand tu sers
des discours, tu sais, tu culpabilises
les jeunes, attention faut pas
consommer, c'est faut la décroissance,
pas faire d'enfants, évidemment, tu vas
pas faire des enfants, tu c'est c'est
angoissant, tuas tu as un climat
angoissant et et en plus bon, un
problème peut-être de fertilité, enfin
on sait pas tout ça, mais tout ça pour
dire que ça c'est ça veut dire que ça on
verra les impacts dans 20 ans, dans 25
ans, ça c'est extrêmement.
Donc c'est demain.
Ouais, bien sûr que c'est demain. Bah
nous on sera vieux à ce moment-là. Mais
je veux dire
surtout toi,
surtout moi. Merci. Mais ce que je par
là c'est que voilà vous avez compris
qu'il est plus jeune que moi. Voilà
c'est parce que les gens me demandent
oui il est plus jeune que moi
effectivement mais toujours que
beaucoup
merci merci c'est gentil merci
amenez-moi l'appel je finir l'enterrer.
Bah donne ton âge et voilà ça ira plus
vite.
Ah bah elle veut pas. OK
donc tu vois donc ça veut dire que là on
aura une situation
dangereuse et il y a forc la retraite.
Comment tu vas la financer ta retraite
si tu as pas d'actif ? Tu vois c'est
très très compliqué. Donc pyramide des
âges qui marche sur la tête, le le taux
de natalité en dégringolade,
notre président charismatique et
lumineux Emmanuel Macron qui appelle au
réarmement démographique.
Les femmes, elles ont dû apprécier cette
formulation.
Ouais. Ouais.
Il en fait des bourdes quand même.
Il y a pas que lui, hein. Ensuite, il y
a un problème d'éducation, on a pas de
prof, ils sont pas payés ou sinon
après tu dis que c'est moi qui suis
pessimiste. Ouais. Moi, je suis
réaliste, j'ai pas de lunett j'ai pas de
lunettes rose. Et puis j'essaie de
synthétiser tout ce qu'on a autour de
nous. On a un système énergétique qui
risque d'être sous pression parce que
l'accès aux matières premières, parce
que on n pas le Nordstream qui peut
fiouler avec de du gaz pas très cher.
Mais bon, c'est la guerre et en plus
maintenant les Russes ont fait un autre
stream avec les chinois.
Tu me fais peur, c'est pas la guerre.
Espérons que ça espérons que la guerre
va se terminer. On pense non mais certes
peut-être que cet ép phénomène
tu vi macroniste là fais gaffe. Tu veux
tu veux faire la guerre à tout le monde
toi ?
Non je veux pas faire la guerre à tout
le monde mais comme on fait de
l'anticipation et qu'on fait de la
prospective et qu'on est connecté un peu
partout méfiez-vous. La guerre guer la
guerre on est
je crois que c'est Paul Valérie la
guerre c'est quoi ? C'est un massacre
entre des personnes entre des personnes
qui ne se connaissent pas au profit de
personnes qui se connaissent mais qui ne
se massacrent pas. Donc moi je suis
contre la guerre, sauf si on t'attaque
évidemment mais ça c'est ça c'est
la guerre économique tu fais quoi ?
La guerre économique elle est elle est à
tous les jours. Mais la guerre
économique
tu connais le proverbe ?
Oui oui bien sûr. Le proverbe
proverbe sur le chômeur. Ouais
évidemment
un chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un mort.
Ouais mais ça c'est c'est très dur de
dire ça. Tu
il faut voir les choses en face hein.
Non mais encore une fois ça cette
solution sur moi elle m'effrait. Je dire
oui une bonne guerre et tout. Non
non je te parle pas je dis pas que c'est
toi qui dis ça. Ce que je par là c'est
que ça c'est dangereux. C'est-à-dire que
et justement par rapport à la
décroissance qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure parce qu'on me dit ben voilà
après on va dire on va faire de
l'euthanasie faire tout ça c'est fait tu
as fait grec latin non
euh non
si vispassem parabellom si vispassem
parapassem
ouais
la diplomatie c'est c'est un un autre
sujet
c'est la guerre ou je je connais mais ce
que j'ai pas c'est que ce que j'ai pas
là c'est que il y a il y a une autre
solution que la guerre que tout ça que
la décroissance c'est justement
l'innovation c'est justement
l'investissement vers l'avenir c'est
trouver des nouvelles sources de
création és charismatique et lumineux,
notre grand leader, il a fait un élevage
de l'élevage duas de la licorne là, les
startup nation, les machins nation, les
licornes nation. C'était c'était de
l'arnaque. D'ailleurs, ça qui faut bien
le savoir dans les arnaques,
il a essayé
non mais le nom il est toujours dans
l'arnaque parce que une licorne ça
n'existe pas.
Mais oui donc quand on dit mais c'est
vrai donc ça il faut le savoir.
L'arnaque elle est on le sait comme
qu'on te disait quand justement à
l'époque de la crise des prime on te
disait oui c'est des produits des caves
monétaires dynamiques. Rien que le nom
il y a un problème cav monétaire
dynamique. Monétaire c'est sans risque
dynamique rendement élevé. D'où vient le
rendement c'est qu'il y avait une
arnaque tuis donc l'arnaque on la voit
général tu vois elle est effectivement
prend le contrôle de la sémantique c'est
que ça commence à et de la rhtorique
c'est que ça commence à sentir mauvais.
Exactement.
Je vais prendre une question internet.
Donc je voudrais les enfants s'il vous
plaît que vous fassiez monter par
vous-même les questions les plus
intéressantes ce qui nous évitera de
nous taper toutes les questions à lire
une par une. Je prends la première de
Zilotte. Que pensent-il du mouvement
Nicolas Quipet ? Faut-il baisser les
pensions géantes des boomers et rendre
aux actifs le fruit de leur travail ?
Alors oui mais c'est point c'est
différent dire entre Nicolas qui
effectivement et puis puis les boomers
c'est différent. Non, le gros problème
c'est que dans le Nicolas qui bay c'est
justement la pression fiscale qui est
énorme qui est donc pour tout le monde.
Et le problème c'est quoi ? c'est
qu'effectivement les personnes qui ont
les moyens, ils ont accès à à des à des
conseillers fiscalistes, donc ils vont
réussir à payer moins d'impôts que la
classe moyenne qui n'a pas d'accès
justement à ces conseillers fiscalistes,
donc qui elle va payer plein potôt. Donc
moi, je suis pour une baisse globale des
impôts.
Alors, pardon, tu une fois, il est dans
un monde ouvert et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui. Tous les Français qui ont
qui ont un petit peu d'argent, ils l'ont
pas volé hein, c'est pas des Ils l'ont
gagné. Je vous rappelle que c'est aussi
quand là, tu l'as dit de l'ordre
d'ailleurs le grand danger qui est de
ponctionner l'épargne,
ça c'est quand même dramatique parce que
on me dit souvent je cette cette
remarque. Ouais. Alors vous avez on a
3500 milliards de d'euros d'épargne. Si
on ajoute le hors bilan, ça veut dire le
paiement des retraites des
fonctionnaires, on est à 7000 7500. OK,
c'est énorme. Tu mets en face l'épargne,
tu as 6500 milliards de d'épargne
financière des Français. Donc 6500,
c'est moins que 7500. Donc tu vois vente
de trois cathédrales et c'est même
l'actif non même parce que tu vends tout
l'actif pas qu'on vend tourfel la
tourfel
mais qui va la acheter
chinois ça se vend pas ça se vend pas la
tour efffel
ça se loue
mais encore une fois ça suffira pas
parce que même si tu vends tous les
actifs et bien il te manque encore à peu
près 3500 4000 milliards par rapport à
l'ensemble de la dette donc tu vois tu
arrives pas mais de toute façon on
rembourse pas toute on do pas rembourser
toute la dette d'un seul coup
heureusement encore he
tu sais qu'il y a des gens qui font des
dons à berercis des des patriotes
qui donne qui qui viennent faire des
dons à Ber
et toi aussi tu en fais tu es pas au
courant
si ça les impôt
non ça s'appelle non c'est pas des
doncient
à au salaire des fonctionnair au
salaires des des infirmières en plus des
impôts tu veux dire il voilà en plus des
un téléton pourra brav moi encore une
fois très honnêtement si on est sûr
qu'almet en ponctionnant on va dire
allez 1 % ou 2 % de toute l'épargne des
français on On est sûr qu'après on aura
plus jamais de problème et
qu'effectivement nos dirigeants vont
bien gérer les données publiques.
Tu es venu en licorne toi ? Non.
Alors tu as compris si tu es sûr de ça
moi je dis au paye. OK on y va mais
c'est évident que ça le fera pas.
Rappelle-toi Michel Rocard 1 % la CSG
vous rendez compte c'est réglé. à 9 %
aujourd'hui, 17 % sur l'épargne. Et donc
justement pour revenir sur l'épargne,
très important là, on parle de dette
publique, on parle d'épargne privée, ça
n'a rien à voir. L'épargne privé sont
des personnes donc privées
qui ont mis toute leur vie parfois à
épargner
sur un épargne déjà fiscalisé.
Exactement. Je vous rappelle que
l'épargne c'est quoi ? On a notre revenu
qui est imposé, après on consomme. Là
aussi la consommation c'est imposée TVA.
S'il reste un petit peu, on espère pour
Gre français malheureusement il reste
plus
pour les enfants.
Voilà et bien on épargne pour ces
enfants et cette épargne à part sur le
livréa si vous gagnez un peu d'argent
pam elle est également imposée. Donc ça
veut dire quoi ? Et là, on veut encore
imposer, faire une nouvelle imposition
sur cette épargne. Attendez, encore une
fois, on a cette épargne qui est privée.
Donc elle a elle n'a pas été volée. Elle
a été justement acquise avec grandes
difficultés. Et encore une fois, ça
c'est ça aussi qui qui m'épate quand on
dit oui, il faut que les générations,
donc des boomers entre guillemets
aident les autres. Je suis désolé, tu
l'as dit, je suis grand-père. Quand tu
es grand-père, tu aides tes enfants, tu
aides tes petits enfants. Et ça, je
pense, tu vois, c'est un enjeu de
société parce que moi j'ai je réfléchis
justement, je dit, tu vois,
ça fait faire des économies
bien sûr, mais surtout moi quand j'étais
enfant, mes parents moi je me rappelle
mon père, il me dit toujours moi mon but
dans ma vie c'est que tu sois mieux que
moi, tu vois. Et c'est vrai que la
probabilité était quand même peut-être
élevée. J'aurais pu me planter, j'aurais
pu mal finir, hein. Mais bon,
il avait la froide.
Non, mais surtout c'està-dire que il y
avait encore une croissance. On avait
une probabilité que les enfants soient
mieux que les parents. Aujourd'hui,
malheureusement, cette probabilité, elle
a fondu comme neige au soleil. C'estàd
que toi ni moi, on peut pas garantir que
nos enfants, ils vivront mieux que nous.
Ils auront un meilleur niveau de vie que
nous. C'est ça qui ça qui fait de la
peine. Donc d'un point de vue sociétal,
c'est extrêmement dangereux, tu vois. Et
donc moi, je suis désolé
bien sûr pour aider mes enfants, pour
aider voilà mes petits enfants, pour
aider autour de moi, ce que doit faire
tout français. J'ai pas besoin de l'État
pour faire ça parce qu'en plus je sais
que il va mal le faire. Ah oui parce
qu'il va me ponner mais par contre il va
entretenir les dépenses de
fonctionnement. Il va entretenir euh des
comités théodule. Il va entretenir des
organismes diverses et variés pour faire
plaisir à Pierre Paul à Jacques. Non moi
je préfère aider directement mes
enfants, mes petits-enfants que
effectivement que mon argent soit
utilisé à mauvais essence.
Question internet. Pourquoi la dette
française coûte 3,52 % et le livret A
est à 1,7 % ?
Ah ! Alors ça c'est différent, c'est que
c'est tout le problème, c'est que déjà
le livréa c'est de l'argent qui est
immédiatement disponible. Donc c'est
alors que la dette publique c'est gén
c'est là c'est à 10 ans. D'accord ? Donc
là on est même monté à 360 % hier sur le
taux 10 an plus haut depuis donc
novembre 2020 2011 et donc c'est c'est
pas le même taux, c'est pas le même
marché. Alors que sur effectivement le
le taux du livréa c'est le taux
monétaire on va dire. Donc là
effectivement on est à un peu plus de 2
% mais là où c'est finalement il a par
contre là où il a raison notre
internaute c'est que c'est une décision
de la Banque de France voilà et donc
validé par le gouvernement donc qui
justement réduit massivement ce taux du
livré. Donc on est même pas sur le taux
de marché donc on est plus bas
effectivement que le taux monétaire.
Donc là effectivement c'est une bah oui
c'est une arnaque bien entendu. Et puis
c'est pas une arnaque.
Ah bah si c'est parce que globalement
aujourd'hui tu devrais avoir au moins le
taux de monétaire. Or tu l'as même pas.
Tu connais le fond de garantie des
dépôts bancaires ?
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est combien d'euros par établissement
et par personne ?
100000 €.
Non. Ah
si,
c'est 72000. Je demande à me faire fa
checker les enfants.
Ah bon ? Moi, j'ai entendu 100000 €.
Peut-être que tu as cit ça peut-être
évolué parce que tu es vieux. C'est tu
as pas suivi Michel sapin.
Ah bah si. Et son fameux effet de
levier.
Oui, d'accord. Mais normalement, si
effectivement ta banque dépose le bilan,
fait faillite, ton dépôt garanti jusqu'à
100000 €. Après bon est-ce que derrière
si mes souvenirs sont bon, je crois que
c'est 72000 € par compte et par
rétablissement.
Question internet d'ailleurs ou qui a
été critiqué donc je vais la poser euh
et si on augmentait notre temps de
travail pour générer plus à un coût
similaire ? Oui, moi moi je suis moi je
suis d'accord mais je suis d'accord
surtout pour ne pas imposer. Moi ce qui
m'a ce qui
Ah tu as peut-être raison c'est 100000
euh par client et par étou quand même tu
vois mais tu as vu tu vois que je je
reste humble avec toi c'estàdire je dis
bon tu me
oh tu es trop mag tu es trop bon avec
moi. Non mais c'est ve dire bon mais
c'est sûr que
ministère de l'économie des finances ou
100000 € tu veux le problème c'est que
ça peut tellement changer euh voilà du
jour au lendemain qu'on sait jamais donc
mais normalement c'est 100000 € moi j'ai
merci pour le fact checking
non non mais merci effectivement
donc tu es je suis
donc oui sur le le
sur le travail sur le temps de travail
comme sur la retraite moi je suis pour
laisser le choix au français tu veux
travailler plus OK tu seras payé plus tu
veux partir à la retraite plus tard si
tu peux c'estàd si tu es en bonne santé
et cetera, ben tu seras payé plus. Tu
veux partir avant, tu auras moins de
retraite. Tu vois, il faut aujourd'hui
qu'on ait un ce que on appelle ça un
système de juste prix. Ça veut dire que
que en fonction de ce que tu fais, bah
tu es rémunéré en fonction de ce que tu
as fait, tu vois. Donc moi, je suis
d'accord. Mais ce qui pas ce qui ce qui
colle pas, c'est quand tu imposes, tu
dis aux gens "Ah bah, tu vas devoir
partir à 64 ans, à 65 ans, à 67 ans." Ça
c'est pas dans notre culture. On a quand
même une culture justement de liberté.
Et mais par contre effectivement comme
il y a pas assez d'argent bah il faut
qu'à ce moment-là tu puisses ajuster
arbitrer en fonction de l'argent qu'il
a. Mais tu dois laisser la liberté
effectivement en français.
Question internet. Alors là il te pose
une colle. Je suis sûr que tu as pas vu
l'interview. Ah
parce que là il y a il y a il y a des
fidèles.
Il
y a le cœur.
Désolé.
Quelle est la position de Mark Tati sur
le discours d'Aurore Stéphan sur les
limites planétaires, sur le désastre
écologique en cours et sur leurs
influences sur l'économie de marché ?
Point d'interrogation. Quelle planète
pensent-ils pouvoir laisser à ces petits
enfants pour interation ? Ben c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
effectivement. Alors déjà, on en sait
rien parce que tu vois, il peut pas se
passer tellement de choses. Mais c'est
évident qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
il faut mieux utiliser notre monde. Mais
comme je l'évoquéis tout à l'heure en
Chine parce que nous on aime se
flageller. En Chine tu avais 100
millions qui vivaient correctement. Tu
as 700 millions aujourd'hui. Quand tu
vis correctement bah tu veux bien
manger, tu veux manger de la viande, tu
veux manger du lait et cetera. Donc ça
aussi ça consomme. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Et ce qui est
impressionnant, c'est que quel est
aujourd'hui le pays qui investit le plus
dans la RD, dans la recherche
développement sur les énergies
renouvelables ?
Les Chinois.
Bravo les Chinois. Tu as compris ?
C'estàd que eux pour l'instant c'est eux
qui polluent le plus mais ils ont
compris que c'était un vrai enjeu d'
plus. On a délocalisé notre pollution
chez eux.
Non mais non mais c'est ce que je te
dis. C'estàd que mais eux ils sont en
train de comprendre l'enjeu. Mais pour
eux c'est c'est
tu sais tu sais combien ils produisent
en en gigawatt les Chinois par rapport
aux Européens et par
rapport ou c'est énorme bien sûr mais
c'est les premiers producteurs premiers
pouleurs mondiaux évidemment forcément
en électricité euh si je demande à me
faire fact checker parce que c'est
vraiment de tête et en diagonale de
d'temps. Je crois que les Chinois
produisent trois fois plus que l'Europe
en terme énergétique et et c'est normal
parce que nous si tu veux comme tu l'as
bien dit on a voulu délocaliser notre
production. rappelle-toi dans les années
80 90, on avait encore des dirigeants
français, c'était pas les français, les
dirigeants français qui étaient à côté
de la plaque disait "On veut une
économie française sans usine." Te
souviens de ça ? Et ben donc forcément,
il fallait bien que les usines soient
quelque part. Donc les amis en Chine
ailleurs puis on dit non, on veut
réindustrialiser. Mais quelle erreur de
diagnostic voyez encore une fois, c'est
pas les français, c'est les dirigeants
français qui ont fait n'importe quoi.
Alors là, je vais poser une question
mais il y a pas de point d'interrogation
donc je la lis. J'espère qu'ils ont pas
fait monter la question pour nous faire
des petits pièges avec un système de
crédit lombard entre parenthèses taux
Euribor à 1.5, je découvre la question
en même temps que toi. Taux Euror à 1.5
%. Est-ce que finalement l'objectif de
la finance n'est pas de nous maintenir
dans un état de déficit avec des taux à
5 6 % de manière à draîner via la
fiscalité la richesse des Français au
profit de nos usuriers Advitam et Ternam
? J'explique le système de points
instauré en Lombardie. Le crédit Lombard
permet d'emprunter en hypothéquer son et
d'hypothéquer en hypothéquant son
capital à un taux extrêmement faible. Ce
type de prêt était accessible aux très
grandes fortunes. Ce capital emprunté
nous est alors prêté mais à un taux de 6
%. Dans ce montage, on empoche sans rien
faire la différence de taux et on laisse
travailler l'argent.
Bien sûr. Le problème c'est qu'encore
une fois qui a augmenté la dette
publique ? C'est pas c'est pas les
financiers, tu vois ce que je veux dire
? C'est pas les Français non plus, c'est
les dirigeants français. Donc c'est ça
effectivement ça les enrichit. Qui
aujourd'hui quand tu quand tu dépenses
70 milliards d'euros juste pour les
intérêts de la dette, qui c'est qui va
les empocher ? Ce sont ceux qui
détiennent la dette. Mais qui leur a
demandé de leur prêter de l'argent ?
C'est les États, tu vois. Donc voilà,
tout le problème est là. Après, c'est
effectivement c'est vieux comme le
monde. Il y a une question challenge.
Ah
euh je suis dans la finance de Alors,
bonjour Sky, bonjour à toute l'équipe,
on t'embrasse.
Non, il il a pas mis ça. Je suis dans la
finance depuis 2017 et je connais un peu
tous les youtubeurs entre guillemets. Je
suis désolé mais qu'à dire monsieur
Touati si je lui dis que c'est un père
maère.
Il annonce l'apocalypse depuis au moins
2017 et les marchés n'ont pas arrêté de
monter. Les taux, les actions, la
crypto, toutes les théories économiques
classiques ont été invalidées depuis
2020. Il n'a pas de be market en mode
fin du monde au vu des politiques et de
l'idéologie financière de notre époque.
Il faut buy the deep à chaque fois et ne
jamais détenir de cash.
Ouais, il a raison. Le cache, c'est
vraiment qu' situation extrême bien
entendu. Alors qu'est-ce que tuappelle
le cash ? Parce que dans dans l'idée des
gens, le cash c'est des petits billets
sous le matelas.
Ouais, le cash c'est soit ça, soit que à
la banque non rémunéré. C'est ça en
gros. Mais bon, mais après ça dépend, il
y a des phases malheureusement
l'histoire le montre. Mais sur le perma,
ce que j'évoqué tout à l'heure, perma ça
veut dire que dire que je suis en
permanence BER. Bre c'est les c'est
l'ours. En fait sur les marchés, il y a
il y a le boule, le taureau, c'est le
marché haussier. Puis le ber c'est
l'ours. C'est c'est le baissier. Bon, je
sais pas si je ressemble à un taureau et
ou un ours. J'espère je peux faire un
taureau quand même. Mais bon, toujours
est-il que euh Non, je suis pas perma.
C'està-dire que comme je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure,
tu as pas de lunettes rose
déjà. Mais j'ai non, j'ai souvent été
optimiste en 2009. qui reprennent mes
articles. l'un des rares à dire ça va
redémarrer alors que tout le monde dit
ça y est c'est la fin du monde. J'ai
même écrit un livre resté optimiste qui
s'appelait Krabou mes deux main qui
avait d'ailleurs bien marché en 2009 et
à l'époque tout le monde voyait le
situation complètement catastrophique
cataclysmique moi je dis non ça va
redémarrer et c'est ce qui s'est produit
parce que justement il y avait une
relance énorme ça va fonctionner là
effectivement depuis 2017 il a raison
jevoqué tout à l'heure et effectivement
en 2018 ça ça a plongé sauf que ce que
je n'avais pas effectivement anticipé
c'est la planche habillée
les injections
Ben oui, c'està dire que ça qui peut
anticiper un truc pareil des sommes
aussi énormes et puis surtout
le corona virus où là on a on a là
c'était encore pire l'argent magique.
Donc là je l'avoue hein de après le
coronavirus on a fait on a lâché
tellement d'argent n'importe comment et
c'est maintenant justement qu'on paye la
facture. Donc voilà c'est en train
d'arriver aujourd'hui mais encore une
fois que les marchés montent c'est bien
tant mieux crypto et cetera.
Moi mon révélateur la crypto et l'or
l'or a battu son alors ou ça c'est ça
c'est pas très c'est dangereux. Moi
d'ailleurs ça fait des années que je dis
de je conseille entre guillemets
d'acheter de l'or.
Non non mais ici on n'est pas fait pour
non je d'accord je dis pas non plus mais
je dis depuis des années que je dis
attention l'or va monter et c'est
exactement tu vois on a encore atteint
3600 dollars l'on aujourd'hui. Donc tu
vois bien que on a la situation de oùù
l'or a effectivement augmenté mais c'est
là où c'est paradoxal parce que
normalement quand l'or monte les marchés
baissent et réciproquement là ça va de
concert les marchés boursiers montent et
l'or aussi monte c'est qu'en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Bah, les
investisseurs se disent "Bon, je suis
quand même inquiet donc j'achète de l'or
ce que j'appelle la poire pour la soif
mais finalement comme il y a tellement
de cash, ben les marchés boursés aussi
vont monter." Donc je fais les deux à la
fois. aussi il y a des il y a des
mouvements euh euh de tectonique
géopolitique. Il y a l'Inde, il y a
Chine qui achète chèque. Mais je peux te
dire très honnêtement euh je l'avoue, tu
vois, je fais bien coule pas, je l'ai
fait plusieurs à plusieurs reprises
hein. C'est que on a une situation
aujourd'hui où tu as énormément de
caches dans le monde. Tu as trop de
caches dans le monde. On sait plus ce
que les voil ce que les boises valent.
C'est plus que on a perdu l'échelle des
valeurs et ça c'est vrai que c'est le
coronavirus qui a qui a tout foutu en
l'air parce que on travaillait pas, on
avait un salaire qui tombait euh les les
gens travaillaient pas, ils gagnaient
même plus que quand ils travaillaient.
Incroyable.
Pas tous hein,
pas ben pas nous mais certains. Mais
donc sans parler des arnaques et cetera.
Donc tout ça pour te dire que on a perdu
l'échelle des valeurs. Donc moi
aujourd'hui, je l'avoue très
honnêtement, c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
je fais plus trop de prévision de
boursière, c'est que normalement moi ce
qui me plaisait, ce qui me plaît dans
les marchés action, c'est que on a une
corrélation entre la réalité financière
et la réalité économique. Tu vois, c'est
d'où mon métier. Moi, je suis
économiste, donc je parle de l'économie.
Après, à partir de là, tu fais le
pendant, tu fais le pont avec les
marchés financiers. Là, tu es en
complète déconnexion. Donc évidemment
cette déconnexion, elle peut continuer
jusqu'au jour où effectivement ça sera
stop. Donc c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs je
sur les marchés boursiers non je suis
extrêmement prudent. Par contre ce qu'on
observe c'est que quand il y a des
mouvements de correction, rappelle-toi
le quand Trump a annoncé les droits de
douché boursier s complètement effondré.
Donc ça veut bien dire que les
investires sont quand même très
inquiets. Donc tu as des mouvements
abruts très puissants. Donc prudence
quand même. Voilà, il faut rester
prudent
et on n'est pas là pour donner des
conseils d'investissement.
Bien sûr,
on est des pères de famille. C'estàdire
que tu vois euh ouais moi, mais
c'estàdire qu'il faut même il faut être
moi je préfère la prudence. Tu veux ce
que je dis toujours, le couple rendement
risque. Si tu veux gagner beaucoup, tu
dois prendre des risques. Mais
il faut être prêt à prendre une grosse
éculoté aussi hein.
Voilà. Exactement. Si tu veux pas
prendre de risque, tu dois te contenter
de rendement faible. Après, chacun voit
Midi à sa porte. Moi, j'estime que ce
qui me concerne, je préfère prendre pas
trop de risque au niveau des placements
financiers. J'entends perd.
Voilà, je suis tranquille. Puis c'est
vrai que ça fait pas rêver. Mais bon,
c'est pas grave. Au moins ça fait
kiffer.
Ah bah des fois euh quand la situation
est difficile, les bons pépè rassurent.
Oui, c'est sûr. Mais tu vois, question,
il y a énormément de gens qui me disent
"Pourquoi vous créez pas votre boîte de
gestion et cetera ?" C'est J'ai
tellement peur de décevoir parce que les
gens vont avoir, tu vois, ils ont C'est
pour ça que je suis très en colère
contre les gens qui créent des trucs sur
moi en disant "acheter tel ou tel
produit parce que c'est pas moi
évidemment. Euh et je l'ai jamais fait
parce que justement euh après si ça
marche pas pour x raison, je dis les
gens vont m'en vouloir. Me dis mais
c'est pas mais c'est pas grave, on me
dit euh tu vas te protéger, tu vas dire
que c'est pas de ta faute et que ça oui
quand même tu vois. Donc voilà
question internet doit-on sortir de
l'euro ?
Ah ça c'est une bonne question. C'est
vrai que j'avais écrit un livre en 2012
je crois qui s'appelait quand la zone
euro explosera. Et c'est pas que je
disais qu'elle qu'elle qu'il fallait
qu'elle explose, mais je disais que si
on ne faisait pas un minimum de de
modernisation, elle allait exploser. Et
comme on n pas fait ces modernisations,
évidemment aujourd'hui la zone euro est
en danger. Par contre honnêtement, si
elle explose, je sais pas du tout
comment on s'en sort, tu vois. Et
surtout, c'est ce que j'évoque souvent,
euh la France aujourd'hui n'a pas les
moyens de supporter ce qu'on appelle un
frexite parce que évidemment peut-être
qu'on verra plus clair après. Alors
certains me disent "Oui, mieux vaut une
fin dans l'horreur qu'une horreur sans
fin." Tu connais le discours, voilà
notamment, mais c'est un proverbe. Bon,
mais peu importe. Mais toujours-t-il que
euh moi je suis très honnête, si la zone
euro explose demain, je pense qu'il y
aura une telle déflagration mondiale
également chez nous que on va quand même
perdre pas mal de plumes. Donc on me dit
les anglais avec le Brexit, les Anglais
n'avaient pas l'euro. N'oubliez pas, ils
avaient gardé leur monnaie que nous si
effectivement on change de monnaie, ça
va être très compliqué. Donc après on
peut on peut tenter hein, mais moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la France
n'a pas les reins solides à la rigueur.
Les Allemands, ils pourraient le
supporter. Mais tu sais, il faudrait
qu'on change de monnaie tout de suite
comme ça on on pourrait battre notre
monnaie et mettre le profil de notre
président lumineux et charismatique
Emmanuel. Tu m'inquiètes he tu
m'inquiètes. Tu es amoureux ou quoi ?
Ouais, nous on est gentil avec tout le
monde. Bon, question les gars,
faites-nous des questions courtes parce
que là, c'est des pavés et donc je vais
quand même la poser parce que ça muscle.
Bonsoir, j'ai découvert Mark Tati sur
Syerview et le suis depuis sur sa
chaîne. C'est ma ça cela m'a permis de
mieux orienter mes choix
d'investissement. Alors, tu es pas je
sais pas si tu donnes des conseils
d'investissement sur ta chaîne, mais
ici, on donne pas de conseil
d'investissement.
Il prennent à chaque émission la
diminution de cette fameuse dette
publique qui maintenant nous explose à
la tête.
avec plus de 60 % de la population
doit se mettre pour sa croûte. Faites
des questions en français. J'entends de
plus en plus les gens parler de
révolution. La parole est aisée mais les
actes alors peut-on dire à l'heure
actuelle qu'une couvade
préérévolutionnaire pourrait être
déclenchée par ce 8 septembre avec une
association
de la classe moyenne àri et des gilets
jaunes. Durant les 2 mois de vacances.
toutes les discussions que j'ai eu avec
la tranche d'âge 35 ans, tout le monde
était d'accord, ne serait-il peut-être
pas temps de se lever pour revendiquer
nos droits ? Oui, ben je pense
qu'effectivement c'est imminent, ça
couvre comme je tout à l'heure, moi je
vais beaucoup effectivement en province
et je je retrouve ce discours même
également à Paris hein, faut pas non
plus l'oublier. Et donc ça c'est
inquiétant aussi parce que ça montre que
si tu veux le le le modèle social
français ne fonctionne plus. Le modèle
social français c'était quoi ? C'était
bon là bon ben on paye beaucoup d'impôts
mais on échange. On a la stabilité
sociale, on a on a on vit pas trop mal
et cetera. une certaine sécurité
finalement et tout ça malheureusement a
été battu en brèche. Je sais pas si tu
as vu les chiffres, le taux de pauvreté
a augmenté sur un record historique
cette année. Alors c'est la pauvreté en
France, c'est pas la pauvreté au Brésil,
hein, mais quand même.
Non, mais il y a il y a ce type de de
facteurs qu'on suit. Certes le taux de
pauvreté mais il y a l'augmentation de
violence aux personnes, l'augmentation
des maladies genre moyenageuses,
l'augmentation des viols des des je t'en
passe et des meilleurs. Les gamins qui
se mettent des coups de couteau, c'est
c'est ça va ça va avec le taux de
pauvreté. Non mais moi ça m'inquiète
vraiment et je pense que il faut
quelqu'un qui remette le pays dans
la prostitution est studantine et gens
pass
dans les dans les bons rails. Non les
bons rails le les étudiants qui font la
queue pour avoir les colis alimentaires
et gens ou non mais voilà. Non mais
c'est que tu as l'impression que c'est
que c'est bon ce qu'on appelle un pays
du tiers monde entre guillemets et c'est
vrai que la France elle s'est déclassée.
Je vais donner un chiffre incroyable le
ce qu'on appelle le PIB par habitant
c'est la richesse par habitant en France
dans les années 90 on était 11e du
monde. On était au même niveau que les
Américains, même voir devant les
Américains.
Aujourd'hui on est combien ? 25e du
monde. Donc les Américains sont 5e. Ils
ont augmenté. Nous on s'est déclassé.
Donc c'est ça qui est qui devient
extrêmement dangereux et surtout il y a
pas de d'objectif. C'est là où
effectivement il faut des dirigeants qui
soient proche de la population. Il faut
restaurer la confiance. Sinon
effectivement je suis d'accord, on peut
avoir ce climat insurrectionnel et ce
qui est très grave c'est que justement
il y a encore ce déni de réalité des
dirigeants français qui pourrai
justement faire très mal.
Question internet. Monsieur les faux
d'orthographe aussi hein. Attention
monsieur Toui a mentionné la courbe de
l'affaire. A-t-on démontré et la
visibilité de cette hypothèse ou c'est
juste une dfarfelue des libéraux pour
défendre leur principe d'imposition
minimum pour l'interrogation ? Il me
semble que le cas de figure d'impôts
augmentant n'ont absolument pas eu
d'effet rebond défavorable.
Ah ben si, on l'a prouvé sous François
Hollande. Bah oui, donc c'est pas c'est
pas si vu que ça. C en 2012 si je me
souviens bien. Donc effectivement, il a
augmenté les impôts et sauf que ça a
cassé l'activité économique à la fin il
y a moins de recette fiscale. Donc ça
c'est un exemple type. Et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui que font tous les pays du
monde pour relancer la croissance ? il
baisse les impôts.
Donc voilà, encore une fois, si nous
étions sur un niveau bas d'imposition,
ça pourrait marcher. Nous sommes numéro
1 du monde des impôts, donc ça ne peut
pas fonctionner.
Alors, l'internaute qui avait posé la
question souhaite te répondre et alors
exceptionnellement, je vais lire
ce qu'il veut te répondre. Je souhaite
répondre à monsieur Touatti. Le but
n'est pas de taxer plus et prendre
l'épargne des Français, mais d'aligner
les pensions des boomers sur ce qu'ils
ont cotisé afin de ne plus mettre de
pression fiscale sur les actifs. Donc
baisser le montant des retraites
actuelles. Taxer l'épargne n'aurait pas
de sens. Les boomers touchent deux fois
plus que ce qu'ils ont cotisé. Il y a
aussi une demande de baisse des dépenses
de la GAPJI de l'État qui vit largement
au-dessus de ses moyens. Le problème
c'est que là les boomers gagnent pas
deux fois plus que ce qu'ils ont cotisé.
C'estàd qu'effectivement comme ils
vivent plus longtemps ben forcément mais
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde.
Certains meurent plus tôt après
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? On va les
tuer ? Faire de l'euthanasie.
Non.
Ben oui. Non mais c'est c'est quoi la
solution ? Donc c'est ça qui moi ça qui
m'inquiète dans ce discours.
Tu leur mets le chauffage à 17°gr
t'inquiète.
Non et puis surtout n'oublie pas
l'humidité. Ça c'est les boomers qui
s'en sont sortis globalement. Mais la
moitié des boomers justement ils gagnent
moins de 1500 € par mois.
Ils sont pas propriétaires de leur
logement tu vois. Donc effectivement
peut-être certains
le viège
mais encore une fois ils ont ils ont
cotisé. Donc par contre là où je suis
d'accord bien sûr il faut réduire les
charges qui perdent sur le salaire. Il
faut que quand tu travailles tu gagnes
mieux que quand tu travailles pas.
Question internet.
Est-ce que Marc est allé à Athène voir
un peu l'état de la entre guillemets
Grèce en croissance ? Fermez les
guillemets. Point d'interrogation. Moi,
j'ai vu des murs tagués de partout, des
drogués, une jeunesse qui s'expatria à
l'étranger pendant que les autres
travaillent dans des coffee shop pour
les touristes et ainsi payer les gentils
retraités grecs boomers qui ont le
pouvoir.
Ah bien sûr. Moi je je suis très triste
pour la Grèce. J'y suis allé plus, j'y
vais régulièrement d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai encore gardé quelques clients et
c'est vrai que j'ai vu ce cette cette
ville taguée Athène une ville taguée
même sur les même sur les les musées,
c'est horrible parce que comme il y a
pas de moyen pour pour enlever
effectivement les tags, alors on les
laisse. Non, bien sûr, c'est ce que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure. Quand un quand
quand le PIB baisse de 30 %, ça laisse
des traces pendant des décennies et
comme je l'voué tout à l'heure, le
niveau du PIB, il est encore 15 %
inférieur au niveau de 2008. Donc c'est
sûr que c'est malheureusement d'ailleurs
je l'ai souvent dit à l'époque la Grèce
1 n'aurait pas dû rentrer dans la zone
euro.
C'est c'était une erreur.
Ils étaient pas prêt.
Est-ce que tu me permets à faire
l'avocat du diable ?
Quand il y a eu la crise, ils auraient
dû quitter la zone.
Est-ce que tu peux ne me permet de faire
l'avocat du diable ?
Tu es trop bon Marc. Hein ?
Tu es trop bon avec moi aujourd'hui.
Je suis toujours
mais ça arrangé tout le monde que les
Grecs il viennent diluer. Ça faisait un
Reichark déguisé en euros, du moins un
euro déguisé. C'est ça arrangé quand tu
rentré dans la zone euro.
Ouais. Ça arrangé les Allemands.
Non mais alors là tu vois, je vais te
répondre très clairement. Moi, j'étais
contre une grande zone euro parce que ça
n'a pas de sens. une zone euro, c'est
une une zone monétaire, c'est ce qu'on
appelle normalement une zone monétaire
optimale. Ça veut dire uniquement avec
des pays qui se ressemblent, qui sont
très proches. Ça veut dire avec une
harmonisation des conditions fiscales,
des conditions réglementaires, du marché
du travail, tu vois des pays très
proches.
Toi, tu crois vraiment au père Noël ?
Non mais ce que Non, mais à l'époque, on
aurait pu faire la zone euro avec six
pays, c'est tout. Mais là là il faut
qu'on fasse rentrer l'Ukraine. Là
c'est n'importe quoi. Non mais peut-être
pas dans la zone euro. Peut-être dans
l'Union européenne pas dans la zone
euro. Non mais surtout ça n'a pas de
sens. C'est que tu as des pays beaucoup
trop disparates au sein de la zone euro.
Tu comprends ? Donc ça peut pas marcher.
Ce que j'évoqué justement dans 2012 dans
mon livre quand la zone eur explosera,
ça ne peut pas fonctionner. Il faut que
tu es des pays qui soient unis. Et ça
c'était une erreur, faut le dire. Il a
avoué d'ailleurs de Jospin et Chirac
notamment de Jospin qui a dit nous ce
que tu dison ton ton ta remarque on veut
une zone euro élargi comme ça l'euro
sera faible et surtout comme ça la
France sera pas le dernier de la classe
tu comprends si aujourd'hui tu fais une
autre zone eur une vraie zone euro la
France elle est pas dans la zone euro
parce que
on est avec les pigs
on est plus loin de la France c'est le
pays qui a le moins respecté les règles
de la zone euro depuis sa création te
rends compte que ça soit des sites
publique, la dette publique, on
respecte.
Ouais, mais nous on est les français, on
fait ce qu'on veut.
D'accord. Mais bon, je te dis que cette
zone euro aujourd'hui, si on devait la
créer, la France, elle serait pas
dedans. Donc voilà. Non,
on a Paris, la capitale la plus belle du
monde qui a que 2 milliards de
évidemment qu'on on adore notre pays. La
France est certainement des plus haut
pays du monde, mais on est en train de
le tuer.
Et puis on on a le le port
les dirigeants, je dis quand je dis on
les dirigeants français sont en train de
tuer le P. On a le Chaveli.
Ah non,
Puini Morchet et on a la Corse peut-être
plus pour longtemps. Question internet.
Posteil-t-il une Rolex ?
Tu as pas de montre. Ça c'est pas tech
Philip ou un truc comme ça que tu j'ai
une Rolex que ma femme a fait cadeau il
y a très longtemps mais je la mets pas
parce que j'ai pris le métro pour venir
ici.
Tu as peur de te faire couper la main ?
Non mais c'est pas faut pas provoquer.
Déjà les gens il me reconnaissent plus
ou moins. Alors s'il voit la Rolex on
sait jamais.
Tu vis de l'antisémitisme ou des des
conneries comme ça ?
Non, pas pour l'instant. Des fois ça
peut arriver ça. Ça m'est arrivé parfois
très rarement sur internet, mais c'est
rare, non ? Parce que moi, je communique
pas effectivement à ce niveau-là. Puis
par contre, oui, je je vois que ça
existe et puis moi je suis beaucoup par
mon éparvo donc je me rends pas compte
et et puis bon voilà, j'habite dans dans
Paris, dans les beaux quartiers, dans
voilà, donc on se rend pas tellement
compte. Mais ça que ça existe. Mais ça
que ça existe. Et c'est c'est triste.
C'est triste parce que moi j'ai grandi
justement dans le HLM, on était tous
ensemble et alors des fois on se taper
dessus, des fois on s'engueulait et
cetera mais quand on allait jouer au
foot, voilà, on était ensemble. Je me
dis ça aussi j'en veux aux politiques
quoi. Comment ils ont ils ont ils ont
tué le pays à ce point-là. C'est
qu'aujourd'hui les gens se il y a une
violence, il y a une haine qui est
incroyable parce qu'on ne dit pas les
choses. C'est ça aussi. On on
l'éducation nationale ne fait pas son
boulot.
Faut dire qu'ils ont pas beaucoup
d'argent.
Non non. D'accord. Mais quand même quand
même on on on ne dit pas les choses
quand tu vois tout ce qui se passe que
les les profs ont peur aujourd'hui de
dire certaines choses, de dire des
réalités hein, ils vont pas inventer,
ils préfèrent ne même pas ils enlèvent
du programme. C'est quand même
incroyable. Donc bravo, je leur tire mon
chapeau effectivement à tous ces profs
euh
résistant hein.
Ah non mais ils ont ils ont ils ont un
mérite énorme. Ils ont un mérite énorme.
Et j'
donc 2500 profs quand même hein.
Ouais ouais. Non, mais c'est c'est vrai
que c'est
euh c'est c'est d'ailleurs je profite
pour tirer un coup de chapeau à mon un
de mes anciens qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait Alexandre, je vais pas donner
son nom qui justement qui lui est est
devenu prof si tu veux alors qu'il était
économiste qu'il aurait pu rester après
mais quand je suis parti de Nxis celui
qui m'a enfin qui a pris ma place entre
guillemets, il était tellement mauvais
que il a préféré partir. Mais bon,
toujours est-il que euh voilà ça c'est
un mec formidable. Je l'aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs, je vous rappelle de temps en
temps parce que quelqu'un qui était dans
la banque, il avait un bon salaire, il a
dit "Non, je vais aller être je vais
faire l'enseignement à la fac et au
lycée justement pour euh euh parce que
c'est important d'essayer de de dire les
choses, de dire la vérité. Bravo à lui,
bravo à tous les autres."
On en profite pour dire à notre
communauté, soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a
besoin de vous pour pouvoir continuer,
pour continuer à inviter qui on veut,
quand on veut, discuter autant de temps
qu'on veut, sans pub, sans exil fiscal,
sans mess, sans sans oligarques de la
presse et et et payer notre expert
comptable et et tout ça. Euh question
internet. Euh non, je vais poser une
question moi.
Ouais,
tu m'autorises bien sûr. Je suis là ce
soir avec moi. Le FMI euh tu
Après par contre je commence à être main
fatigué donc soit tu me ramènes un petit
whisky ou quelque chose comme ça. Non,
on boit pas d'alcool ici. Tu veux de
l'eau ? Non mais
on ira boire un coup de gibin parce que
je suis ma femme qui m'attend.
D'accord. Euh désolé ta femme, je suis
désolé. C'est OK. Le FMI tu le sens ? Tu
le sens bien ? Tu le sens pas bien ?
Comment
tu vas arriver à Paris ? Ouais,
mais là il faut bien prendre conscience
que le FMI peut intervenir quand il a
les moyens d'intervenir. Dans le cas de
la Grèce, il c'était 350 milliards
d'euros. Bon, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
? a annulé la dette grecque avec le FMI,
la BCE, les l'Union européenne.
On a pas tant annulé que ça. C'estàd
qu'il y a la dette la dette junior, la
dette senior.
Oui oui, on l' annulé puis on a reprêté
350 milliards avec un taux plus bas et
sur des échanges plus longues. Nous la
France c'est 3500 milliards.
On rajoute un zéro. Tu crois que le FMI
va pouvoir nous prêter ce 3500 milliards
? Non. On va devoir se débrouiller les
enfants, tu comprends ? que ça c'est
c'est un peu la tarte à la crème mais il
y aura une sanction évidemment bien
avant si le FM arrive c'est que c'est
vraiment c'est la fin des haricot comme
on dit c'estàd mais je pense que ça ça
aura déjà craqué bien avant qui là ils
veulent savoir le prix de ton slip le
combien coûte ton costume est-ce que
c'est le même costume que notre litter
charismatique illumineux
euh non ça c'est je vais te dire non je
vais pas faire c'est je l'ai acheté non
il coûte pas cher celui-là je crois 250
€ je crois un truc comme ça écoute non
mais tu je veux dire la vérité voilà
parce Maintenant vraiment on est de la
famille presque en fait. Moi j'use
énormément. Non mais c'est vrai mes
vêtements parce que comme je transpire
tout le temps, je fais je suis à droite
à gauche. Voilà, je certains disent que
je suis hyper actif. Bon bref, donc en
fait quand j'achète des marques,
faut que ça tienne le choc.
Ça je les explose comme les les Ça c'est
pas une super marque mais bon mais donc
je me dis là c'est j'aime bien aussi bon
j'ai pas donné de pub mais j'aime bien
certains costumes mais voilà mais moi je
paye voilà j'ai pour moi 250. Tu
es vachement bien habillé. J'adore ta
cravate. Bon, change gentil. 300 € le
costume, ça suffit. Ça sert à rien de
payer un costume 1000 € parce que de
toute façon, je vais l'exploser comme un
costume à 300 €. Euh, on arrive à la fin
de notre interview parce que sinon ta
femme va nous tirer les oreilles. Euh,
est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ouh là, là en ce moment, tu veux dire ou
euh
tu dis quoi ? Qu'est-ce que tu
conseilles à notre communauté pour se
muscler le cerveau ou pour comprendre
l'arborescence de ton raisonnement ?
comment tu construis ton raisonnement ou
ce qui t'a marqué, ce qui
Moi, moi j'aime bien si tu veux, moi je
j'ai un livre de chevé entre guillemets.
Alors, j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai deux. Un,
tu vas tu vas tu vas rigoler, c'est la
Bible. parlé tout à l'heure de la Bible,
je pense c'est très important de lire
euh c'est tu c dans un autre monde.
Alors des fois tu tu as des passages un
peu durs, c'est costaud mais bon voilà
c'est bien. Et euh le deuxième livre là
c'est on change plus économique le livre
de Kens théorie générale qui est
formidable. Moi je le lis en anglais,
j'aime bien le relire parce qu'en fait
cet économiste est un économiste anglais
qui a sauvé le monde, faut pas
l'oublier. C'est lui
fait beaucoup de dettes quand même.
Oui, mais juste mais à l'époque c'était
donc il est arrivé à la après la crise
de 29 et c'était nouveau parce que à
l'époque ça existait pas justement la
relance et cetera. C'est c'est lui qui
l'a créé. Il a conseillé Roosevelt et
donc et c'est ce qui a permis de
relancer la machine mais par contre ce
que savent pas les gens les gens
notamment les français c'est-à-dire les
les dirigeants français c'est que il y a
une suite c'est pas que lui c'est pas
que la relance qu'on dit la relance
kénésienne qu'est-ce qu'il dit Kens Kens
un grand libéral parce que les gens
comprennent pas Kens en fait il disait
faut effectivement relancer la machine
quand ça va mal mais dès que ça va mieux
là l'état se retire et on retrouve un
équilibre voir un excédent budgétaire
qui permettra de relancer la machine
lors de la prochaine crise, tu vois.
Donc Ken, c'était pas du tout quelqu'un
de gauche, tu vois, je dirais un
méchant.
Oui, aussi c'est pas mal. C'est bien.
Mais lui, lui, il est lui il est euh il
est quand même c'est presque un peu
trop. Et puis surtout moi je
moi je suis pas pour la rigueur, tu
sais. La rigueur pour la rigueur la
saigné, c'était au Moyen-Âge, quoi, tu
vois. C'est fini ça. Donc non, moi je
trouve qu'il y a effectivement un juste
un juste milieu qu'on qu'on va trouver.
Euh le troisème
alors c'est marrant, j'ai j'ai oublié le
nom. C'est c'est un livre que m'a passé
mon fils parce que malheureusement mon
fils enfin heureusement pour lui je sais
pas il s'est mis aussi dans la finance
tu vois.
C'est comme papa.
Mais non mais moi je voulais pas
j'aurais prévu qu'il soit ingénieur et
cetera. Bon il va m'en vouloir que je
dise ça mais bon et finalement il est
très bon hein. Il est très il sera il
sera même bientôt je vous dirais je
aller investir chez lui il va sûement
créer sa boîte.
On va peut-être le recevoir. Ben
j'espère bien. J'espère j'espère parce
qu'il est il est très bon. Il est
meilleur que moi, je le dis hein. Et
parce que c'est une nouvelle génération.
Voilà, tout simplement. Et il comprend
des trucs que moi je comprenais pas.
Peus, tu es un peu convaincu parce que
c'est ton fiston.
Non, c'est parce que en fait si tu veux,
je pense que comme on a on a un vécu, tu
vois, on a une on a vécu une autre
période qui pour moi était quand même
plus sympa que celle qu'on vit
aujourd'hui. Bon, peu importe, c'est mon
opinion. Il y a des trucs, il y a des
mécanismes, tu vois, qu'on capte pas, tu
vois, par exemple, sur les cryptonnaies,
tu vois. Bon, je sais que certains m'en
ont voulu. Moi le Bitcoin, on me l'a
proposé quand il valait 1 € un dollar
plutôt et j'ai pas cru, je dire
honnêtement parce que j'ai pas cru.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je me suis dit les
autorités elles vont légiférer, elles
vont pas laisser faire ça parce que il y
a aucun contrôle, il y a aucune
transparence, tu vois. Alors bien sûr
techniquement c'est super et cetera et
puis ils ont ils l'ont pas fait tu vois.
Et c'est vrai que c'est amusant parce
que je raconte une anecdote y a il y a
pas longtemps, j'ai fait j'étais à Las
Vegas faire une conférence. Moi, je joue
pas au jeu mais bon, j'y suis allé.
Enfin bref, c'était un une boîte les
jeux quoi.
Non, une boîte qui faisait ça. Donc bon,
c'est marrant Las Vegas. Et donc je me
suis dit, je me suis fait la même
référence qu'avec le Bitcoin. C'est dire
quand tu réfléchis Las Vegas c'est quoi
?
C'est une ville montée par des truants.
Non,
c'est ça. Non, c'est c'est une ville en
plein désert au milieu de rien qui a été
créée pour blanchir de l'argent, faut le
dire, par des mafieux, par la mafia
américaine et puis d'autres mafias et
cetera.
Bitcoin, c'est pas ça, hein.
Non, j'ai pas dit ça. J'ai pas dit que
c'est Big B. Tu as compris le truc de
cétait donc à la base sur le papier ça
devait pas marcher. C'était impossible
que ça marche et pourtant c'est devenu
incontournable. Tuant on fait même des
conférences. Bon c'est c'est une ville
un peu bizarre quand même mais bon dire
que bah voilà les cryptomonnaies à la
base ça devait pas marcher. C'està dire
que les autorités auraient dû légiférer.
Elles n'ont elles ont laissé faire et
dedans tu as de tout. C'està dire
effectivement et donc mais j'ai oublié
le titre du livre parce qu'il m'a passé
un livre que je suis en train de lire et
j'ai oublié le titre. Ça c'est euh je
deviens vieux, tu vois. Mais et donc
c'est un livre justement sur comment
effectivement investir
euh et et gagner effectivement et y
compris avec les cryptomonnaie. Donc
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est euh je je
tu vois je m'y mets hein.
Donc on n'est pas là pour conseiller des
placements financiers ou quoi que ce
soit, je le répète. Non non non pas du
tout, pas du tout. Mais euh mais voilà
mais ça pour dire que faire tuer ta
femme.
Ouais ben oui, ça sera ta faute. Moi
aussi. Non je rigole. Et je l'embrasse
d'ailleurs. Non c'est aussi a des amis
qui t'aiment beaucoup d'ailleurs enfin
qui aiment beaucoup ta chaîne que je je
vais avoir ce soir parce que demain je
parle étranger. Bon peu importe. Et donc
toujours est-il que donc je dois les
voir et donc aussi je vais je vais les
voir plus tard mais euh toujours est-il
que donc voilà donc euh oui, on a
effectivement ces euh ces
investissements donc euh on apprend tous
les jours. Moi je pense que l'économie,
c'est ce que j'aime dans l'économie,
c'est une leçon d'humilité permanente.
C'està dire que des fois en fait tu peux
pas avoir de certitude. Tu en as
certaines par exemple l'offre et la
demande tu vois voilà le couple
rendement risque. Mais c'est une matière
qui évolue avec le temps. Et ça qui est
qui est beau, tu vois. Et et ce que
j'aime quand même, c'est et c'est pour
ça je suis content du de la chaîne
YouTube, c'est qu'effectivement on reste
dans le dans le dans le coup. On reste
dans le coup. Et moi ce qui me fait
plaisir, c'est quand je vois tous ces
jeunes qui m'envoient des messages qui
me disent voilà, on vous suit et et ça
me fait plaisir, tu vois, parce que je
préfère ces jeunes là évidemment que les
jeunes qui vont se dire voilà on va
voter pour des partis qui prennent le
retour de l'URSS et cetera, tu vois.
Donc ça ça fait peur quand même parce
que c'est quand même notre jeunesse,
c'est quand même notre avenir qu'ils
veulent tout casser, tu vois. Moi quand
je quand je venais desciter HLM euh dans
ma jeunesse, donc ben je voulais pas
tout casser, je voulais m'en sortir, tu
vois. J'avais cette volonté de de créer
de créer des choses, tu vois. J'adore
créer, tu vois. Et euh et depuis voilà,
quand je vois des jeunes aujourd'hui qui
ont envie de détruire, je me dis c'est
quand même c'est quand même bizarre.
Tu connais le proverbe ?
Résister, c'est créer. Créer, c'est
résister.
Ouais, exactement. Euh donc
donc on continuera de créer,
on on nous demande des questions sur
l'intelligence économique. Euh on n' pas
le temps les gars, je suis désolé. Ça
fait déjà 2h26 qu'on est en interview.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Vas-y, allez-y
placer une dernière question. Euh on va
essayer de lui en passer une une
dernière. Est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ? Une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose qui
restera impérissable sur internet. Moi,
je dis aux jeunes génération
deux choses. Déjà, la valeur travail,
c'estàdire qu'en fait parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui, on a l'impression
qu'on peut gagner de l'argent très
facilement, voilà, avec les
cryptomonnaies, avec les réseaux sociaux
et cetera.
Le travail c'est indispensable. Moi j'ai
voulu que mes enfants bon ils l'ont fait
de même et je suis content qu'il l' fait
qu'il fassent un minimum d'études si tu
veux pour avoir voilà un background pour
pour commencer effectivement avec ces
études avoir cette réussite parce que
avoir des diplômes c'est quand même une
réussite tu vois et voilà et après il y
a effectivement la valeur de travail
c'est très important c'est le plus
important peut-être et surtout se
réaliser dans le travail moi j'ai eu
cette chance je je j'ai j'ai une chance
formidable c'est que j'aime mon métier
il Moi voilà quand je travaille pour moi
c'est pas du travail c'està dire c'est
du plaisir quand je viens ce soir c'est
du plaisir quand je fais mes conférences
c'est du plaisir quand je vais à la télé
quand je vais aller c'est du plaisir
quand je fais mes équations. C'est du
plaisir. Quand je fais mes prévisions,
quand je fais mes vidéos YouTube c'est
du plaisir. C'est fatiguant des fois
parce que des fois bon on a d'autres
choses à se faire mais on a envie de se
reposer. Mais c'est du plaisir et ça
c'est une chance énorme. Donc voilà je
pense que le conseil que je donne c'est
d'arriver à concilier justement le
travail et le plaisir. Et et n'oubliez
jamais une chose, l'argent n'est pas une
fin en soi. L'argent c'est un moyen.
C'est dire c'est un moyen pour profiter
de la vie, pour bien vivre, pour avoir
besoin de personne. Parce que c'est ça
en fait le drame, le plus grand des
drames, c'est d'avoir besoin de
quelqu'un d'autre, d'avoir besoin de
de travailler émancipateur,
voilà. et d'avoir cette liberté et euh
et j'espère qu'on on pourra sauver la
France parce que on ne le dit pas assez.
La France c'est un pays qui est
formidable. Tu vois quand je vois
aujourd'hui tu parlais effectivement de
l'antisémitisme et cetera, mais je vois
beaucoup de gens.
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire ?
Formidable.
Ouais. Vas-y, dis-le. Tu me dis tout à
l'heure. Donc je vais pas te
formidable de formidau qui veut dire
terrifiant.
Terrifiant. Mais ça c'est terrifiant.
C'estàd que c'est ça qui c'est à la fois
beau mais quand c'est beau c'est aussi
terrifiant. Tu vois quand j'ai des gens
aujourd'hui qui me disent
ta femme elle va elle va apprécier.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Non. Qui me disent
qui me disent "Je vais je veux je vais
quitter la France tous les jours." Ça
m'arrive tu vois sur des messages comme
toi tu y est fermé ma boîte, je quitte
la France. Mon meilleur choix ça été
d'avoir quitté la France il y a 15 ans,
il y a 10 ans. Je me dire c'est triste
parce que la France est quand même un
pays formidable et et d'en arriver là.
Mais moi j'y pense. Je te dis la vérité,
moi aussi j'y pense. C'est c'est grave
d'en arriver là. Et c'est là où j'en
veux quand même à nos dirigeants qui
nous ont mis dans une telle situation
parce que
c'est pour ça que nous français, il faut
se battre pour le pays. Il faut que
il faut être fort.
Non, bien sûr. Non, mais on a rien sans
rien. Donc il faut se battre et il faut
aussi voilà, tu l'as dit, voter, faire
en sorte qu'il y ait des gens qui qui
qui ont envie de sauver la France, tu
vois. Et parce que la France c'est un
grand pays, tu vois. Mais tu vois, je
l'ai j'ai vu comme tous les dirigeants
français depuis 30 ans, je leur dise
toujours, vous savez, je leur dis encore
aujourd'hui, soit on arrive à se
moderniser dans la douceur, soit dans la
douleur. Et on aurait pu le faire dans
la douceur, mais malheureusement par
manque de courage, par manque de volonté
aussi,
ben on l'a pas fait. Donc maintenant, je
je suis désolé de le dire, on va devoir
se moderniser
dans la douleur. C'est inévitable parce
que parce que nos dirigeants nous ont
mis dans dans une telle situation. Et
moi je je dis à aux économistes, aux
autres qui disent "Non, mais tout va
bien, arrêtez de faire peur." Je veux
pas faire peur moi, je veux juste faire
prendre conscience de ce qui est en
train de se passer pour qu'on puisse
réagir et sauver la France parce qu'elle
le mérite tout simplement. Et je veux
pas laisser la France à des gens qui
veulent la détruire. les gens qui vous
proposent, on va pas donner de nom et
cetera, mais tout ce qui propose là,
bref, voyez qui sont certains qui sont
rassemblé qui foutent de la pagaille en
permanente à l'assemblée là, qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent détruire la France ? Ils
vivent sur la destruction. Moi, je pense
qu'on doit construire. Moi, je suis un
constructeur. Je pense qu'il faut
construire, il faut créer. Eux sont des
destructeurs et ça c'est très dangereux
pour l'avenir du club.
C'est ta lecture.
Bien sûr, bien sûr, bien sûr. Non, mais
il faut de tout mais en quoi il faut
débattre, tu comprends ? il faut
débattre et mais quand les gens te
disent "Non mais c'est nous qui avons
raison", non, on peut débattre, tu vois.
Et et donc c'est ça qui est dangereux
parce que après c'est quoi le chemin
d'après ? C'est la dictature tu vois.
Donc voilà, espérons qu'on va sauver
effectivement la France.
Marc Toati, merci. Bah avec plaisir mon
cher Sky et faire plaisir. Bonjour
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et c'était un
plaisir d'être ça aussi quand on me dit
vous arrêtez de dire toutes et à tous
dites tous pour moi c'est de la
politesse, c'est pas du walkisme. Moi je
suis antiw antiwer à 200 % on a 28 % de
femmes dans notre communauté.
Exactement. Pour moi, c'est je moi j'ai
été élevé comme ça. C'estàd que même
quand je fais mes conférences, ça fait
30 ans que je fais des conférences.
Quand je commence, j'ai toujours bonjour
à toutes et à tous. Pour moi, c'est de
la politesse envers les dames, envers
les hommes, tu vois. Mais c'est pas du
wisme. Donc je lis ça aussi. Donc j'en
profite parce que ici on peut tout dire.
Donc voilà. et on peut tout dire si on
prend le temps d'échanger que ce soit
carré cubique et que il y a les s ains
de suite.
Voilà ce que je voulais dire également
c'est que voilà moi je ce que je pense
qu'on doit donner c'est de l'amour. Moi
ce que je donne dans mes dans mes vidéos
et cetera, non mais c'est vrai c'est de
l'amour. C'est-à-dire que je pense qu'il
faut s'aimer. On s'aime pas assez et
plutôt que se détester. Et donc voilà
ceux qui me des fois m'envoient des
messages méchants, je je les bloque tout
de suite parce que on peut on peut ne
pas être d'accord mais il faut être
gentil. Tu vois, il faut voilà, il faut
être poli et c'est ça aujourd'hui
l'enjeu. Et quand certains voilà mettent
des bâtons dans les roues à un très haut
niveau, je trouve ça c'est moi je trouve
ça violent, je trouve ça très grave, tu
vois ? Parce que moi qu'est-ce que je
veux ? Je veux juste donner de l'amour
et je veux dire très honnêtement, je
vais tout faire pour euh pour rester en
France, pour continuer le combat, mais
si vraiment un jour je vois que je peux
plus, que qu'on s'en prend à moi, tu
vois, vraiment, ben évidemment, je
resterai pas, tu vois. Donc, j'espère
que ça n'arrivera jamais. Mais ça, c'est
le message que je lance effectivement.
Donc merci à tous ceux qui me
soutiennent. Ça me fait vraiment chaud
au cœur à tous les messages que j'ai en
permanence. C'est vraiment formidable et
c'est vrai que ça me donne une force
pour continuer et comme à toi, je pense,
j'imagine
et à ce moment-là et ça fait plaisir de
se dire voilà, il y a des gens
qui ont envie de sauver la France et et
donc je pense qu'on pourra sauver la
France avec de l'amour.
Marc Tati, merci. Avec plaisir.
[Musique]